ja meine damen und herren das ist live
ein bisschen hart der übergang aber wir
müssen leider den
bundeswirtschaftsminister unterbrechen
denn jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
ressort justiz und
bundesverfassungsgericht und franziska
hoppermann ist die erste rednerin sie
ist die berichterstatterin der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
das sowieso schon überforderte
umweltministerium nun auch noch um den
verbraucherschutz erweitert wurde
immerhin würde man ja denken dass die
ohne den verbraucherschutz im
justizministerium dann jetzt mehr zeit
für justiz themen händen leider
fehlanzeige
der etat des generalbundesanwalts wird
weiterhin bei den personalausgaben und
drei millionen euro gekürzt trotz
stellen schaffen haben sie diese
kürzungen nicht zurückgenommen dafür
setzen sie sich den eigenen personal
etat des ministeriums weiter hoch das
ist bei den aktuellen herausforderungen
wo gefahren dass ich meine kolleginnen
der normenkontrollrat wird ins
justizministerium verlagert weg vom
kanzleramt er ist also nicht mehr
chefsache für den normenkontrollrat ist
dies eine degradierung und es schadet
der wirksamkeit dieses wichtigen rats
das deutsche patent und markenamt wird
von ihnen noch im mai bei ihrem besuch
umschmeichelt wie wichtig doch der
beitrag sei in das patent und markenamt
zb bei der bekämpfung der
produktpiraterie leisten könnte wie aber
auch der bdi der markenverband und der
aktionskreis gegen produkt und
markenpiraterie kritisieren sind die
dafür erforderlichen stellen in ihrem
haushaltsplan nicht vorgesehen dabei
haben wir in der letzten regierung eine
umfangreiche reform und stärkung mit dem
gesetz über weitere aufgaben das patent
und markenamtes umgesetzt nun müssen
aber auch die dafür erforderlichen
ressourcen vor
darum im haushalt 23 sie haben im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart den pakt
für den rechtsstaat zu verstetigen und
den vitalpark brecht zusätzlich zu
schließen die verhandlungen zur
weiterführung haben aber immer noch
nicht angefangen der alte pakt für den
rechtsstaat ist im januar ausgelaufen
ihre staatssekretärin der minister
schiebt gegenüber den ländern
verfassungsrechtliche bedenken vor dabei
müssten sie schlicht das weiterführen
was von der großen koalition schon
umgesetzt war die länder warten dringend
auf die einhaltung ihrer vollmundigen
versprechen und ankündigungen
vielleicht wäre es nur optionen man mit
umsätzen anzufangen und weniger auf
tassen verbringen
bisher sind sie mehr ankündigungs als
justizminister die länder sind derart
verärgert dass sie in dieser stunde
parallel zu dieser debatte einen
beschluss veröffentlichen mit dem
abstimmungsergebnis 16 zu null der sie
auffordert beim pakt für den rechtsstaat
und die digital packt recht endlich
tätig zu werden
ja der digital packt recht muss neu
ausgehandelt werden haben sie verstanden
dass man dafür mal mit den ländern reden
müsste aber sie haben hier im bundestag
noch im april gesagt sie hätten bereits
mit a und b ländern verhandlungen
begonnen
tatsächlich aber haben sie erst nach der
sitzung und zwar im mai einladung fürs
erste gespräch verschickt ehrlich gesagt
habe ich gerade von einem justizminister
dass er hier keine umbau hätten erzählt
und ich frage mich ob sie überhaupt die
gremien richtig kennen und ob sie zum
beispiel wissen was der justice rad
wirklich macht die länder wissen sehr
genau welche schritte es in der
digitalisierung der justiz braucht ich
habe das gefühl dass ihnen ernsthaft die
orientierung fehlt dem digital packt
recht richtig anzugehen
dabei hat die fdp als sie noch in der
opposition zwar gebetsmühlenartig der
damaligen spd justizministerin für
lamprecht vorgeworfen endlich mehr ein
digital packt rechts zu tun oder
innenstadt an thome und viele andere
haben das hier mehrfach angemahnt
im haushaltsausschuss sagten sie mir
dass sie das direkt mit dem
justizministerinnen und justizminister
besprechen wollen auf der
justizministerkonferenz
diese findet allerdings gestern und
heute in bayern statt sie nimmt daran
aber gar nicht teil
zum amtsantritt wäre das aber genau
angemessen unmöglich gewesen eine
spontane digitale schalte außerhalb der
tagesordnung ersetzt das nicht das ist
schon ein deutliches armutszeugnis und
eine deutliche missachtung der länder
die heutige debatte entschuldigte ihr
fehlen gestern und heute dort nicht für
dienstliche es bekanntermaßen
vielfältige beförderungsmöglichkeiten
die
verteidigungsministerin hätte sie das
sicherlich gut beraten können die
flugbereitschaft kann man als kabinetts
nicht also nicht nur für
familienausflüge nutzen sondern sogar
für dienstlich ist
insgesamt ist der haushaltsentwurf für
das justizministerium unambitioniert und
setzt die falschen signale sie kürzen an
den falschen stellen und vor allem
setzen sie durch die verzögerung beim
pakt für den rechtsstaat und die digital
fakt recht den schulterschluss mit den
ländern auch spielen wir werden daher
diesen haushalt ablehnen
franziska hofmann von der cdu/csu sie
ist dem berichterstatterin für ihre
fraktion und sie soll ja im september
stellvertretende cdu generalsekretärin
werden zumindest wenn es nach friedrich
merz den parteivorsitz angeht jetzt hat
direkt der zuständige minister das wort
nämlich marco buschmann der
bundesfinanzminister von halo und der
bundesjustizminister von der fdp
und kollegen
nach über drei monaten
hat der schreckliche
angriffskrieg wladimir putins gegen die
ukraine nichts an seinen schrecken
verloren
wir hören jeden tag von toten wir lesen
jeden tag über verwundete wir bekommen
jeden tag berichte über die
bombardierung von städten und die
vernichtung
lebensnotwendiger infrastruktur gehören
das jeden tag
und obwohl wir es jeden tag hören dürfen
wir uns daran nicht als etwas
alltägliches gewöhnen meine damen und
herren
mit diesen schrecklichen nachrichten
sind auch nachrichten über
kriegsverbrechen verbunden und man muss
es immer wieder sagen auch krieg findet
nicht im rechtsfreien raum statt es ist
die aufgabe der internationalen
gemeinschaft das völkerstrafrecht zu
verteidigen meine damen und ja
ich engagiere mich dafür mit meinem haus
und sicherlich auch mit der
rückendeckung dieses ganzen hauses sehr
intensiv dafür der internationale
gerichtshof der internationale
strafgerichtshof
ermitteln bereits wir koordinieren uns
international wir arbeiten an änderungen
für die rechtsgrundlagen von eur just um
uns in europa noch besser zu
koordinieren wir haben mit dem
generalbundesanwalt eine der
anklagebehörden die mit zu den ersten
gehören die ein struktur
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet haben
und im gegensatz zu dem eindruck der
hier versucht wird zu vermitteln stärken
wir mit dem haushalt 2022
[Applaus]
über die rechten zwei neue referate ein
die den schwerpunkt haben in diesem
struktur ermittlungsverfahren zu
unterstützen weil das aufgaben sind die
uns auf dauer beschäftigen werden weil
das viele jahre in anspruch nehmen wird
die tausenden die hunderttausende von
hinweise auszuwerten und ich bin stolz
darauf dass wir es möglich gemacht haben
denn egal bundesanwalt in dieser weise
zu stärken meine damen und herren wir
werden auch nicht
sonst international koordinieren ich
werde in kürze in die usa reisen und
dort mit meinem amerikanischen
amtskollegen marica darüber sprechen wie
wir noch besser noch koordinierter
gemeinsam als internationale
gemeinschaft vorgehen gegen
kriegsverbrechen denn eines sind wir
unserer verantwortung aus der geschichte
schuldig nirgendwo dürfen sich
kriegsverbrecher sicher führen erst
recht nicht hier in deutschland meine
damen und herren wir
stärken nicht nur den
generalbundesanwalt wir stärken auch
andere institutionen beispielsweise das
bundesamt für justiz weil es viele
zusätzliche aufgaben in den letzten
jahren bekommen hat wir sorgen dafür
dass sich der standort konsolidieren
kann und die behörde nicht mehr
verstreut ist über das gesamte
stadtgebiet von bonn und ihr stärken
natürlich auch das deutsche patent und
markenamt wir tun da es in struktureller
weise betonen dass mit zusätzlichen
stellen wir stärken auch im übrigen den
standort jena und das ist übrigens auch
kein liebesdienst wie immer wieder so
getan wird weil wir es schaffen dass
hochqualifizierte personal das wir dort
brauchen nämlich leichter in jena zu
finden weil münchen ist ein
fantastischer standort aber es
hochgradig umkämpft gerade bei
technischen berufen und deshalb bin ich
sehr dankbar dass wir diesen standort
stärken können ich bin auch der stadt
jena und seinem oberbürgermeister thomas
nitsche dankbar dass wir dort eine gute
heimat für den zweiten strang und
wir bekommen mit diesem haushalt auch
nicht nur den normenkontrollrat und das
möchte ich hier mal sagen ich bedanke
mich bei allen ernannten mitgliedern für
ihre wichtige arbeit und wenn ihr so
getan werde als sei diese arbeit dadurch
weniger wichtig dass wir uns jetzt um
personal themen kümmern als das im
bundeskanzleramt ist möchte ich mich
auch ein stück weit dafür entschuldigen
ich möchte den mitgliedern des
normenkontrollrats sagen ihre arbeit ist
wichtig sie bleibt wichtig sie ist
unverzichtbar wir wertschätzen sie
wir werden darüber hinaus auch
willkommen heißen im geschäftsbereich
des bmj die deutsche stiftung
datenschutz datenschutz ist ein
wichtiges element in der modernen
digitalen gesellschaft und ich betrachte
das als ein stück stärkung dass wir auch
dort die finanzielle grundlage der
stiftung gestärkt haben so ein gutes
signal für den datenschutz
bedanke mich auch für die mittel für
eine überwachungs gesamtrechnung denn
dahinter steckt hier eine philosophie
dahinter steckt die philosophie dass
wenn der staat ihnen die rechte der
bürger eingreift dass er dafür
begründungspflicht ich ist und dafür
keine mutmaßungen reichen sondern dass
wir das wissenschaftlich fundiert und
evidenzbasiert machen meine damen und
herren oder auch das sein gutes signal
für den geschäftsbereichen hat
in diesem zusammenhang möchte ich zwei
dinge sagen und es wundert mich dass das
hier nicht gesagt wurde weil heute
morgen wurde ja in der debatte über den
haushalt
so getan als gäbe es große probleme und
große zwistigkeiten innerhalb der
koalition bei der bekämpfung
beispielsweise von kinderpornografie da
habe ich jetzt gar nichts morgen gehört
also irgendwie sagt die union mal so
oder so aber dazu möchte ich in zwei
dinge sagen dazu möchte ich ihm zwei
dinge sagen wer tatsächlich advokatur
übernimmt für eine chat kontrolle
vergreift sich an der privatsphäre von
millionen von menschen der
kinderschutzbund der kinderschutz sagt
das ist ein unvernünftiges instrument
und der kinderschutzverein sagt sogar es
sei vorgeschoben die das kindeswohl die
in anspruch zu nehmen dieses instrument
durchzusetzen rein sie sich ein in die
geschlossene fonds der ampelkoalition
chat kontrollen haben im rechtsstaat
nichts verloren alle reden über cyber
sicherheit und dann sollen wir
sicherheitslücken auf macht und
einen letzten gedanken und dann könnte
ich auch zum schluss kau präsidenten
gilt das auch für die
vorratsdatenspeicherung die sie heute
morgen wieder erwähnt haben seit über
zehn jahren ist die antwort auf alle
fragen der union nicht 42 sondern die
vorratsdatenspeicherung organisierte
kriminalität
vorratsdatenspeicherung terrorismus
vorratsdatenspeicherung immer so als
würden wir den ermittlern etwas
wegnehmen aber spätestens seit 2017 gibt
es keine vorratsdatenspeicherung mehr
sie wird nicht angewendet und wir führen
instrumente eigentlich ist es nichts
durch ein etwas ersetzen bestärken
freiheit und damit auch sicherheit
herzlichen dank meine damen
mag muss man hier mit seinen
ausführungen zum einzelplan 7 er hat in
diesem jahr 298 millionen euro mehr
unter anderem wird eine million euro für
die stiftung datenschutz gebraucht die
bisher über den einzelplan des
bundesinnenministers geflossen ist jetzt
stefan brandner für die fdp für die
aber das justizministerium ein tempel
des rechts personell bestückt und
geleitet von gelegentlich zugegebenen
langweiligen aber selbstbewussten
juristen und politikern man diese phase
endet kann ich ihnen nicht genau sagen
jedenfalls aber bei der erste erste
richtige tiefpunkt in der geschichte des
justizministeriums heiko maas 1 heiko
maas der als zensur minister in die
geschichte eingehen wird gefolgt von
katharina war lady keine zeit hatte sich
als weiterer tiefpunkt zu etablieren das
war nur ein durchlauferhitzer auf dem
weg ins europäische parlament aber der
richtige sprung kam damit christiane
christine lambrecht die als hass und
hetze und verfechterin im kampf gegen
rechts in die geschichte eingehen wird
dann wirklich absoluter tiefpunkt denn
nur dadurch endete dass sie gemerkt hat
die flugbereitschaft ist für das
justizministerium nicht zuständig
deshalb gegen die partei die jungs
ministerium machte ihren nur zweiter
also so ist er nun kommt marco buschmann
der
zugegeben herr buschmann noch nicht
genug zeit hatte sich als weiterer
tiefpunkt in der leitung des
ministeriums zu etablieren aber mir
schwant nichts gutes dekonstruktion der
familie die für alle und für viele
eltern teil 1 und 2 oder auch mutter 1
und 2 eltern milch spender
verantwortungs gemeinschaften kampf
gegen rechts und vorbereitung von
freiheitsbeschränkungen im herbst das
könnte man meinen der horrormeldungen
aus der bild zeitung sind es aber nicht
es ist das arbeitsprogramm dieses
justizministers das nichts gutes
erwarten lässt
es sieht so aus als wenn es um viel des
tages geht aber nicht um justiz und
recht sieht auch so aus als hätte sich
die hellbraune koalition vorgenommen in
seinem familienrecht keinen stein auf
dem andern zu lassen die regen zur zeit
über reproduktive selbstbestimmung
analog oder im zusammenhang mit der
abschaffung des paragraphen 219 1 bgb
also dem werbeverbot für
schwangerschaften ist also nur eine
frage der zeit sobald diese
verteidigungslinie gefallen ist dass die
abtreibung legalisiert wird
wahrscheinlich bis unmittelbar vor der
geburt über allem steht mein körper
gehört mir bewegung die allerdings zu
zeiten des impfens ganz ganz leise war
also mein körper gehört mir hätte ich
mir bei der debatte sehr gewünscht
diskutierten vor einiger zeit noch über
den er für alle
besteht nun inzwischen völlig vor dem
aus wir reden über
verantwortungsgemeinschaft und einer
beliebigen anzahl von menschen die sich
da analog herr buschmann hat noch so
formuliert wie eine gmbh wie eine
aktiengesellschaft die eine
kommanditgesellschaft zusammenfinden
können verantwortung füreinander
übernehmen der beliebigkeit ist tür und
tor geöffnet die gleichmacherei kommt
auf alle eltern zu jedes kind soll
künftig quasi beliebig viele sogenannte
eltern haben ganz gleich ob die biologie
etwas anderes vor gibt oder nicht mein
name kernstadt elbstadt politisierung
der justiz müssen wir eine
entpolitisierung der justiz betreiben
zurück zu den wurzeln der justiz finger
weg von eltern und von kindern und von
der familie letztendlich habe noch das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch dass nur
noch ein schatten seiner selbst der
einzelplan debattieren wir hier ja auch
zum willfährigen ableger der altparteien
politik leider vorkommen in zeiten von
corona wir hoffen für das
bundesverfassungsgericht dass es auf den
rechten weg zurückfindet und das sage
ich bewusst als ehemaliges langjähriges
cdu-mitglied dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht unter einem cdu
präsidentin auf den rechten weg
zurückfinden und das wird was es einmal
war nämlich ein bollwerk für demokratie
für freiheit und für wie lange
die nächste rednerin in dieser debatte
ist es der dächer für die spd fraktion
ist sie die zuständige
berichterstatterin
wir leben gerade verabredet dass sie
jetzt diese zeit nutzen um auch ihre
wahl abzugeben
demokratische werte sind unsterblich mit
diesen worten wird heute am 2 juni
2022 an die ermordung des kasseler
regierungspräsidenten dr weiter ludger
ebbert über vier jahre war der cdu
politiker der in meinem wahlkreis in
esther wohnte im netz angefeindet worden
weil er starts verachtenden
zwischenrufen von rechtsradikalen
störern bei einer infoveranstaltung zu
flüchtlingsunterkünften die stirn bot
und weil er haltung zeigt und ihnen
zurief es lohnt sich in unserem land zu
leben da muss man für werte eintreten
und wer diese werte nicht vertritt der
kann jederzeit dieses land verlassen
wenn er nicht einverstanden ist für
diese unerschrockene haltung und
insbesondere wegen dieser einstellung
gegen rechtsextremismus musste er mit
seinem leben bezahlen weiter lücke was
stets offen für sachliche kritik auch
wenn wir da auch nicht immer einer
meinung waren aber er forderte ein
klares bekenntnis zu unserer demokratie
zu unserer verfassung und zu unserem
rechtsstaat er wird mir und sicherlich
auch ihnen geschätzte kolleginnen und
kollegen als vorbild für die
verteidigung und bewahrung unserer
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
in erinnerung bleiben
demokratische werte sind unsterblich und
dass diese werte um sterblich bleiben
dafür braucht es einen starken
rechtsstaat in den alle bürgerinnen und
bürger vertrauen haben und dieses
vertrauen ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit sondern braucht
vor allem eine gut ausgestattete justiz
dazu hat die große koalition den park
für den rechtsstaat gemeinsam mit den
ländern auf den weg gebracht und 220
millionen euro zur verfügung gestellt um
2000 neue stellen zu schaffen nach
artikel 30 und des grundgesetzes ist die
ausübung der staatlichen befugnisse und
die erfüllung der staatlichen aufgaben
originär sache der länder
der deutsche richterbund stellt aktuell
fest dass 41 prozent der richterinnen
und richter beziehungsweise
staatsanwälte und staatsanwältinnen bis
2030 das heißt also innerhalb der
nächsten acht jahre in pension gehen die
ampel koalition hat daher auch im neuen
koalitionsvertrag
formuliert wie verstetigen mit den
ländern den pakt für den rechtsstaat und
erweitern gehen um einen digital pakt
für die justiz und das ist auch gut so
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aber als haushälterin will ich diese
wichtige aufgabe die ich keineswegs
infrage stelle unter dem gesichtspunkt
der finanzierung in dem länder und im
bundeshaushalt beleuchten nach der
statistik des bundesamtes für justiz
waren ende dezember 2018 beim bund und
den ländern
21 1338 richterinnen und richter
beschäftigt ende 2020 waren es 21 1942
also 604 mir bei den
staatsanwaltschaften waren 2018 noch
5800 280 staatsanwältinnen und
staatsanwälte ende 2020 weil zuwachs auf
6107 90 stellen zu verzeichnen also ein
plus von 315 stellen und werden nicht
gezählt hat merkte dass wir in diesen
zwei jahren aufwuchs hatten von 915 die
in der statistik erfasst sind mehr
anstellen auf mehrfache nachfragen wurde
uns aber immer mitgeteilt dass bis heute
sogar mehr als 2000 stellen geschaffen
worden seien also innerhalb der letzten
anderthalb jahre müssten dann noch mal
mindestens 1200 dazu bekommen seien die
zahlen die in uns aber nicht foren sind
offenbar nicht feststellbar und das kann
als haushälter sich so nicht hingenommen
werden kolleginnen und kollegen bei
einer neuauflage und verstetigung dieses
paktes habe ich daher die erwartung dass
bei finanzieller unterstützung des
bundes erstens auf eine transparente
umsetzung in den ländern erfolgt und
zweitens die länder nicht auf kosten des
bundes ihre länderhaushalte sanieren und
drittens neueinstellung nicht nur die
pensionierungswelle auffallen sondern
rechtsstaat weiterhin verlässlich für
die zukunftsaufgaben machen
[Applaus]
werden wir auch die ankündigung des
ministers verfolgen der bereits
umfangreiche vorschläge zur
digitalisierung der justiz unterbreitet
für digitale gerichtssäle ziel für
gerichtliche online verfahren für die
digitale dokumentation und für eine
strafrechtliche hauptverhandlung dadurch
schaffen wir einen zeitgemäßen modernen
und bürger freien die freundlichen
zugang zur justiz
neue stellen den staat schon erwähnt
weil generation des anwalt gewährleisten
unsere innere und äußere sicherheit
durch ermittlungstätigkeiten bei
terroristischen gewalttaten an
landesverrat und bei straftaten nach dem
völkerstrafgesetzbuch
derzeit ganz aktuell auf das hat er muss
man schon erwähnt die struktur
ermittlungsverfahren wegen des
angriffskriegs putins gegen die ukraine
wir haben in der bundesrepublik in
vielen fällen gutes handwerkszeug das
heißt in diesem fall gute gesetze und
straftaten zu verfolgen
wichtig und daher wichtig ist es auch
dass wir das personal zur verfügung
stellen dass dieses recht anwendet und
auch durchsetzt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und da muss ich sagen da kann
ich ihnen nicht ganz recht geben wenn
sie den einzelplan länger begleiten dann
werden sie merken
das auch gerade eine große kritik in den
letzten jahren war das gerade in diesen
personalintensiven haushalt eben viele
viele stellen erstmal unbesetzt bleiben
und daher kann ich ihnen das ist kein
quatsch das können sie im haushalt nach
kopplung des pins nachfragen was ist
jetzt nein rufen begleitet ihn schon
fünfter und setzt ihre kollegen und
kolleginnen man das in der letzten
legislatur festgestellt die fdp alle wir
haben nachgefragt und das liegt einfach
an dem schwierigen
stellenbesetzungsverfahren das
ausgeschrieben werden muss und dass man
eben für gewisse positionen erst auf
meinem gewissen durchlauf haben muss zum
beispiel beim generalbundesanwalt man
kann nicht einfach von der hochschule
beim generalbundesanwalt anfang der kann
sich leute ausbilden sondern der brauch
bereits erfahren ermittlerin und
ermittler und die müssen abgeordnet
werden von den ländern und derzeit ist
es so dass die länder den leuten
verwirrend dass sie sich beim
generalbundesanwalt zu erwerben weil die
ihre
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter nicht
hergeben wollen
danke aber sie haben die anderen
abschließend geht mein dank an alle
müssen richter statt doch unsere und die
mitarbeitenden dem ministerium die in
den letzten zehn wochen unter hochdruck
gearbeitet haben und insgesamt gehen wir
davon aus und wir werden sie auch davon
überzeugen legen wir als ampelkoalition
einen soliden bundeshaushalt vor mit
einem justiz haushalt der auf aktuelle
herausforderungen
und die justiz fortschrittlich aufstellt
daher
ist dadurch die spd abgeordneter hat
völlig recht in ihrer rede darauf
hingewiesen dass der cdu-politiker
walter lübke heute vor drei jahren von
dem rechtsextremisten stefan ernst
erschossen worden ist stellt ein ernstes
mittlerweile zu lebenslänglicher haft
verurteilt worden weiter lobte war
regierungspräsident in kassel und
vordächer kommt ebenfalls daher nächste
rednerin jetzt klarer bünger für die
linke
und so lange drauf hauen bis ich nichts
man sollte dich vergewaltigen ich werde
mir den knallern schaffen einfach
abknallen das sind alles zitate aus dem
internet wie wir sie tagtäglich finden
können und wissen sie was genau vor drei
jahren passiert ist
walter wurde von einem neonazi mit einem
kopfschuss ermordet ein video in dem er
sich für einen solidarischen umgang mit
geflüchteten ausgesprochen hatte ging
viral und führte über jahre zu
zahlreichen todesdrohungen im internet
am zweiten
2019 also genau heute vor drei jahren
wurde er dann ermorden
hass im internet ist gefährlich kannst
du tödlicher gewalt in der realen welt
taktik werden menschen in den sozialen
medien
menschenverachtenden aussagen
konfrontiert
einer umfrage zufolge erlebten mehr als
drei viertel der dort in deutschland
lebenden menschen schon einmal hass im
netz sie werden beschimpft beleidigt
verächtlich gemacht und sogar mit dem
tode bedroht sehr häufig richtet sich
hassrede gegen marginalisierte gruppen
mit dem ziel diese herabzuwürdigen und
einzuschüchtern besonders betroffen sind
wenig überraschend frauen die zusätzlich
noch vermehrt sexistischen beleidigungen
ausgesetzt sind wie häufig wusste ich
untertrieb kommentare mit aufrufen zur
vergewaltigung lehnen natascha strobl
und jasmin am grünen kunden sind
beispiele für einflussreiche frauen die
sich aus dem internet zeitweilig
zurückziehen mussten oder sogar ihren
wohnort ändern muss und weil sie und
ihre familien bedroht wurden wir dürfen
nicht zulassen dass menschen die so
wichtige arbeit leisten angegriffen
werden und so versucht wird sie aus dem
öffentlichen diskurs zu verdrängen
das ganze sicher
es ist nicht zeitgemäß das auf hassreden
immer noch keine ausreichenden
konsequenzen folgen das gesetzespaket
gegen rechtsextremismus und
hasskriminalität beziehungsweise die
verschärfung des netzwerk durchsetzung
des gesetzes ist nahezu wirkungslos wenn
die umsetzung nicht funktioniert es
beginnt damit dass gewalt im digitalen
raum vielfach nicht ernst genommen wird
und ermittlung gegen straftaten im netz
gar nicht erst aufgenommen werden oder
bis ins unendliche verschleppt die täter
können oft unerkannt und ohne jegliche
konsequenzen ihren hass verbreiten sie
sehen das internet als rechtsfreien raum
an indem sie sich vermeintlich
ungestraft austoben zwar ist das
internet nicht rechts frei aber leider
viel zu oft rechtsdurchsetzung frei das
bedeutet dass solche straftaten nicht
ausreichend verfolgt werden straftaten
die sich im internet abspielen sind
nicht an einem bundesland gefunden der
tatort ist das internet selbst was in
jedem bundesland das gleiche internet
ist es kann nicht sein dass täter in
einem bundesland mit einer straftat
davonkommen einem anderen für die selbe
straftat verurteilt werden es bedarf
einer bundesweiten antwort dass man auch
nicht sendung ist zdf-magazin royal von
ihren wimmer waren vergangene woche auch
in der breiten öffentlichkeit bekannt
dass jetzt auch noch gegen polizisten
ermittelt wird wegen strafvereitelung
macht die ganze misere eigentlich noch
mal deutlich und zeigt primus viel mehr
passieren das internet ist kein neuland
mehr und das sollte auch für die justiz
für die polizeibehörden langsam klar so
fasst kommentare dürfen weder
verharmlost noch länger hingenommen
geschweige denn als kavaliersdelikt
abgetan werden es müssen dringend mehr
mittel für schulungen zur verfügung
gestellt werden um den hass und die
straftaten im internet zum effektiv zu
bekämpfen so wie es auch die kollegin
von der spd gerade angedeutet online
anzeigen müssen ausgebaut werden besser
zugänglich gemacht werden und es muss
möglich sein auch anonyme anzeige zu
erstatten offer beratungsstellen fordern
das alles ist schon sehr sehr lange hats
kommentare im internet müssen von der
polizei und der justiz genauso als reale
bedrohung wahrgenommen werden wie
beleidigung und bedrohung in der realen
welt darüber hinaus müssen die opfer von
hass weder viel besser geschützt werden
es braucht eine bessere finanzielle
ausstattung der beratungsstellen für
opfer rechter und rassistischer gewalt
außerdem kann es nicht sein dass die
betroffenen auf der polizeiwache ein
zweites mal sie fühlen sich angesprochen
und das ist richtig so die wiederum dass
die häufigsten auch in der
viele tiere rechte rassistischer und
antisemitischer und sexistischer
beleidigungen im internet sind viel zu
lange verschont geblieben daran muss
sich dringend etwas ändern und gut dass
sie sich angesprochen
ihr verein und darf nicht länger
straflos sein und dafür braucht es mehr
effektiveren schutz und mehr mittel auch
im bundeshaushalt
[Applaus]
herr kollege wenn ich das jetzt richtig
gehört habe ausrichtung der afd dann
unterstellen sie der kollegin klara
bünger
gewalttätige handlungen die ich nicht
wiederholen will die sie nicht jemand
anders
und dafür erteile ich ihnen hiermit ein
ordnungsruf der
nächste gegner ist doch paket städten
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ja frau becker sie haben es richtig
angesprochen jan böhmermann
polizeikontrolle war ja in der tat ein
interessanter befund über die frage wie
effektiv funktioniert die
strafverfolgung bei straftaten internet
und das natürlich nicht nur ein thema
der polizei denn strafverfolgung ist ja
aufgabe der justiz die polizei hilft
dann dabei und der befund war sehr
ernüchternd also 16 bundesländer wurden
die gleichen straftaten angezeigt bei
einigen wurde die anzeigen gar nicht
erst angenommen andere haben die dann
ganz schnell eingestellt nach neun
monaten kannte man die täter immer noch
nicht das war sehr interessant oder was
ganz unbekannt blieb in einem fall also
in baden württemberg hat es mal geklappt
wurde jemand verurteilt in anderen
bundesländern wurde der gleiche täter
noch gesucht also es gab keinen
austausch über die frage und deswegen
ist es natürlich ein sehr deutlicher und
auch sehr besorgnis erregender befund
über die digitale realität unserer
strafverfolgung und deswegen ist die
frage der digitalisierung so
entscheidend also wir das ändern wollen
dann müssen wir tatsächlich das
hinkriegen diesen umschwung der
digitalisierung jetzt hinzukriegen und
ich begrüße dass der bundesminister
dieses thema sich sehr stark auf die
fahnen geschrieben habe es ist ein
umdenken in vielen arbeitsablauf ich bin
auch überzeugt das recht selbst wird
sich verändern aber das gute ist alle
sind bereit die bürgerinnen und bürger
haben sich längst daran gewöhnt dass man
ganz viele dinge online erledigen kann
die justiz sie hat sich sogar auch mal
bewegt wir haben seit jahren den § 128
in der zivilprozessordnung wo man
digital verhandeln kann in der korona
pandemie haben wir alle entdeckt ist
eigentlich ganz feine sache als die
leute wissen jetzt wie es geht die
anwältin anwälte haben sich sogar an das
elektronische anwalts postfach gewöhnt
und benutzen das jetzt videos die
landesjustizverwaltungen haben viele
prozesse in gang gesetzt elektronische
akte auf den weg gebrachten all das alle
sind bereit und jetzt gilt es den knoten
durchzuschlagen entsprechend
durchzustarten und das braucht dann
natürlich auch die aktivität des bundes
und deswegen ist so zentral
deswegen ist es nur zentral dass wir den
pakt für den rechtsstaat in den
mittelpunkt stellen auch gerade der
debatte hier weil wir den haushalt
sprechen denn wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass die verfahren ineinandergreifen
dass wir einheitliche standards
einheitliche schnittstellen haben und
deswegen müssen wir natürlich auch über
geld reden damit dass dann am ende
funktioniert denn das beispiel was will
man auf gemacht hat hat ja gezeigt ohne
sinnvolle koordination dort wo die
grenzen von bundesländern überschritten
werden funktioniert es am ende nicht und
deswegen
deswegen brauchen wir diese koordination
durch den bund und der bund muss eben
eine aktive rolle einnehmen um dann
dafür zu sorgen dass das ohne
reibungsverluste funktioniert und dazu
haben wir verschiedene hebel der bund
kann bestimmte gesetze ändern er kann
bestimmte standards in diesen gesetzen
vor definieren und er kann natürlich
fördern dass die länder sinnvoll
zusammenarbeitet und da ist die frage
das geld ist natürlich ein ganz
entscheidender faktor weil die
voraussetzungen den ländern nun mal
unterschiedlich sind und wenn das so ist
dass es eine bundesland weiter voran ist
und das andere nicht was ist das
ergebnis das ergebnis dass entweder gar
nicht kommuniziert wird oder ist das fax
benutzt wird oder es braucht die
menschliche schnittstelle also in
komplexen strafverfahren fahren dann
polizeibeamte mit ihrem laptop unter dem
arm von hamburg nach münchen klappen
ihren laptop in münchen auf um dann die
daten abzugleichen das ist der bestand
und das können wir natürlich so und
nicht nicht so kann das so nicht
zufriedenstellen
wir brauchen tatsächlich diesen
durchbruch dazu braucht das das
qualifizierte personal bei den ländern
was dafür sorgt dass alle jetzt
mitmachen dass wir zeitnah auf diesen
stand kommen und deswegen ist es auch
richtig dass wir im rahmen der
koalitionsverhandlungen diesen pakt für
den rechtsstaat klar benannt haben wir
haben wir eine zahl auch besprochen 500
millionen pro jahr war eine hausnummer
und deswegen ist der auftrag aus dem
koalitionsvertrag
aus meiner sicht ganz klar und jetzt wo
es auch 13.30 ist zwar noch nicht ganz
aber jetzt können wir tatsächlich reden
mit ergebnis der justizministerkonferenz
die einen hohenschwangau in schöner
weise er jetzt auch eindeutig gesagt
haben wir sind auch bereit wir würden
gerne in die verhandlungen einsteigen
und deswegen ist es auch ganz richtig
dass wir das jetzt machen ich selber hat
ja bei dem letzten takt für den
rechtsstaat auf länderseite
mitverhandelt und es war natürlich schon
wichtig und erforderlich dass die
damalige bundesjustizministerin katarina
barley die verschiedenen enden
zusammengebracht hat auch wenn sie nicht
alleine für alles zuständig war und
deswegen bin ich mir auch sicher dass
herr buschmann dass auch für diese
neuauflage des pakts und rechtsstaat tun
wird eins ist klar
was nichts bringen wird ist das jeweils
man mit dem finger aufeinander zeigt ich
jedenfalls habe darauf keinen bock ich
glaube eine gute effiziente
bürgerfreundliche justiz zu
gewährleisten dass die aufgabe aller
staatlichen kräfte legen wir los
sagt till steffen von den bündnisgrünen
der minister debattiert über den
grenzwerten 7 justiz und
bundesverfassungsgericht und die nächste
rednerin kommt von der csu andrea
lindholz stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen der haushalt
des
bundesjustizministeriums und den es
heute geht er ist einer der kleinsten
einzelpläne aber er ist ein sehr
bedeutender einzelplan denn ein
funktionierender und gut ausgestattet
der rechtsstaat ist eine zentrale säule
unsere demokratie die bundesregierung
hat den justizbereich viele große
maßnahmen und reformen angekündigt aber
konkretes geliefert und vor allem zügig
auf die herausforderungen dieser zeit
reagiert hat
nicht das zeigt sich unter anderem
bei der umsetzung der eu sanktionen
gegenüber russland beim schutz vor
kindesmissbrauch und beim umgang mit dem
pakt für den rechtsstaat der pakt für
den rechtsstaat zwischen bund und
ländern stammt aus der letzten
wahlperiode und dort hat der rund 220
milliarden an die länder gezahlt und
diese haben im gegenzug stellt für
staatsanwälte und richter geschaffen
nämlich rund 2000 und unser anreiz hat
damals wirkung gezeigt sie selbst lieber
herr buschmann haben den pakt hier im
bundestag im mai noch als leuchtendes
beispiel für eine parteiübergreifende
zusammenarbeit gelobt und sie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel haben
korrekter und richtigerweise im
koalitionsvertrag auf eine verstetigung
der mittel vorgesehen diese mittel sind
nötig und neben den mitteln ist es auch
nötig dass wir den digital pack bekommen
herr kollege dr grün hat es vorhin
angesprochen in der rede davor und ich
möchte das hier nochmal nachdrücklich
unterstützen im spiegel werden sie
lieber herr minister am 20 05 von ihren
eigenen ampel kollegen kritisiert man
unterstellt ihnen mangelndes interesse
ich darf nur zurufen das sehen sie
zuhauf für die länder dass der pakt für
den rechtsstaat fortgesetzt wird sie
haben im einzelplan hierfür keine mittel
vorgesehen auch nicht für den digital
packt und das ist sehr sehr enttäuschend
sie hatten ein einsehen beim
generalbundesanwalt
die personalaufstockungen und auch den
aufbau der beiden referat zur struktur
ermittlung wegen kriegsverbrechen
begrüßen wir wirklich ausdrücklich und
auch ihr lob an den gba und sein team
ist mehr als gerechtfertigt wir sind
damit vorbild in ganz europa aber lieber
herr bundesminister es reicht nicht das
personal aufzustocken es muss auch mit
mitteln hinterlegt werden das fehlt und
deshalb bleibt der etat des
generalbundesanwalt ist unterfinanziert
und das halten wir für einen erheblichen
fehler
das zögern der bundesregierung bei der
umsetzung der eu sanktion gegenüber
russland verwundert uns nach wie vor um
ihre wirkung zu entfalten müssen diese
sanktionen in deutschland schnell und
wirksam umgesetzt werden und sie lieber
herr buschmann haben hier in der
regierungsbefragung am elften fünften
mitgeteilt wir die bundesregierung tun
alles was wir können mit dem mitte mai
geschlossen sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz der ampel haben sie aber gerade
nicht alles getan was sie können
oligarchen dürfen weiterhin
immobilien schiffe und autos die
eingefroren sind bei uns benutzen und
die verantwortung für die durchsetzung
die haben sie den ländern und kommunen
aufs auge gedrückt wobei wir alle genau
wissen dass sie dazu effektiv nicht in
der lage sind das muss der bund
erledigen und deshalb liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der selbsternannten
fortschritts koalition fortschritt sieht
anders aus
und wir können uns hier ein beispiel
italien nehmen wir hatten in dieser
woche die italienische justiz ministerin
zu gast im rechtsausschuss italien hat
1,8 milliarden euro bereits eingefroren
italien hat nötige gesetze bereits ende
märz verändert italien ist
beispielgebend auch verdient bei den
sanktions bei der sanktions durchsetzung
in ganz europa für europa denn die
europäische kommission arbeitet aktuell
an einem vorschlag zu einem
einheitlichen und härteren vorgehen bei
der durchsetzung der sanktionen und
sanktions verletzungen und ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass solcher fortschritt und
solche initiativen aus deutschland und
vom deutschen justiz minister kommen
zum schluss lieber herr kollege
buschmann noch ein ganz zentrales thema
das mir ganz besonders am herzen liegt
und dass ich mit weniger schaum vorm
mund vortragen möchte als sie das vorhin
getan haben es geht um nichts anderes
als um den kampf gegen kindesmissbrauch
und kinderpornographie und ich muss
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin etwas
eigentlich noch auch als mutter
erschüttert über ihren auftritt gerade
eben wir wissen dass die zahlen in
diesem bereich die aktuellen zahlen des
bka liegen vor sich verdoppelt haben wir
hatten erst anfang der woche ein
wiederum erneut schockierenden fall aus
wermelskirchen in nordrhein westfalen
wir wissen dass wir in den letzten fünf
jahren
19.950 hinweise in diesem bereich die
wir aus den usa bekommen haben in
deutschland nicht aufklären konnten und
wir wissen ermittler wissen dass die
ip-adressen oft der einzige hinweis auf
den täter sind und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen beamten ja
unsere vorratsdatenspeicherung die
gesetzliche grundlage muss geändert
werden aber ich bin der
bundesinnenminister bin sehr dankbar
dass sie erst gestern gesagt hat
wörtlich sie will die speicherung von
ip-adressen verlangen und ich darf sie
ganz herzlich darum bitten sie müssen ja
jetzt eine veränderung vornehmen sorgen
sie dafür dass die ip adressen
gespeichert werden dürfen und zwar nicht
in ihrer placebo lösung mit den quick
freeze verfahren sondern generell für
einen bestimmten zeitraum anders los wie
ist euer gehirn zugebilligt hat wieder
heute gesagt hat das ist in ordnung ist
und sie müssen ja auch nicht länger
abwarten die stellungnahme des bgh ist
klar wir können jetzt handeln und wir
müssen nicht noch wochen weiter warten
datenschutz liebe kolleginnen kollegen
darf nicht zum täterschutz werden und
kindesmissbrauch kindesmissbrauch ist
eines der schlimmsten verbrechen dass es
in unserem land
zu guter letzt will ich noch sagen
schauen sie sich den eu
kommissionsvorschlag ein bisschen
genauer an es ist zu einfach zu
behaupten man wolle dort eine anlasslose
speicherung es ist schlicht falsch es
geht um risikoanalyse es geht und
einrichtung eines zentrums gegen
kindesmissbrauch und kinderpornografie
und vieles andere andere und ich finde
es unerträglich dass es hier in einem
den atem falsches licht gerückt denn
auch heute morgen komm heim kollegen
coole und ich hoffe dass sie eher in
richtung unserer innenministerin
schlagen als in richtung des
fdp-kollegen coole frau präsidentin und
vielen dank dankeschön
für die fdp fraktion erhält jetzt
thorsten liebt das wort des
stellvertretender vorsitzender des
rechtsausschusses und auch
berichterstatter der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen sehr geehrter herr
minister glaube es muss jetzt ein
bisschen umbauen an der stelle ich fange
mal bei ihnen angst vor kolleginnen
kollegin hoppermann wenn ich mir vorhin
den beitrag und ihr klein klein so
angehört habe zum haushalt ist bei mir
ganz klar der eindruck entstanden
eigentlich hat die koalition
rechtspolitisch alles richtig gemacht
wenn sie sich einen kleinen kleinen nur
abarbeiten müssen keinen einzigen
rechtspolitische impuls abgeliefert
haben vorverlegen
aber eines will ich doch als haushälter
loswerden an der stelle zu den ganzen
punkten wie sie vorhin angesprochen
haben ich habe mein gedächtnis kabel
noch mal versucht meinem ipad
aufzufrischen wo sind eigentlich ganz
änderungsanträge zum einzelplan und
sieben gewesen sie dinge angesprochen
haben liebe liebe frau kollegin
und und triebe liebe freundin
tatsächlich alles wiederholen was marco
buschmann finde ich ganz wichtig gesagt
hat und konstantin coole heute morgen
aber diese verliebtheit der cdu csu
fraktion und die erwartungshaltung in ip
adressen die macht mich ehrlich gesagt
nach zehn jahren rechten anwaltspraxis
ist fassungslos ich lassen sich glaube
ich noch mal wirklich sehr ernsthaft
informieren was geht was nicht geht was
wir damit arbeiten können und vor allem
gehen sie doch in der praxis davon aus
den großflächig ip-adressen abgegeben
erfasst werden werden sie genau nicht
die täterinnen und täter erreichen weil
die verschwinden nämlich allem das wird
alles gar nicht funktionieren sie sind
auf dem holzweg
[Applaus]
da ist aber die digitalisierung stellt
unsere gesellschaft vor große
herausforderungen das sind wir uns hier
alle einig ihn so aus und wir müssen uns
dabei auf fundamentale fragen ob die
strukturen in denen wir heute unterwegs
sind diesen herausforderungen gerecht
werden da gibt es glaube ich eine ganze
menge zu tun da ist es richtig dass wir
als koalition gerade im rechtsbereich
auf digitalisierungs maßnahmen einen
großen schwerpunkt setzen digital
verkündete gesetze die digitale wirkung
halten alleine das papier das das
erspart es auch ein echter
nachhaltigkeit beitrag notarieller
online online-verfahren
erweiterung des digitalen
gesellschaftsrecht und besonderes
lieblingskind von mir auch die
verstetigung der digitalen
hauptversammlung damit kommen wir
rechtsstaatlich in dem bereich endlich
an die spitze und das ist dringend nötig
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
zentral und doch das thema ist schon
kurz angesprochen für die
digitalisierung des rechtsstaates auch
die frage nach dem schutz unter nutzung
von daten mit der stiftung datenschutz
haben wir in deutschland bereits
angekommen kompetente informations und
diskussionsplattform und nachdem ich
gucke die kolleginnen kollegen von der
union an gerade sie versucht haben in
der letzten wahlperiode die stiftung
auszuhungern ist es jetzt gelungen sie
nicht nur neu beim bmj anzusiedeln
sondern auch finanziell so zu stärken
dass sie endlich ihre arbeit machen kann
dabei bleibt aber natürlich natürlich
nicht stehen der pakt für den
rechtsstaat ist angesprochen oder
digital pakt für justiz deswegen möchte
ich das thema gerne auch nochmal
aufgreifen ja erst richtig und notwendig
denn eine digitalisierung des
rechtsstaates hat ja auch was mit der
attraktivität von justiz berufen zu tun
auch da haben wir nämlich dringenden
nachholbedarf aber eines muss doch klar
sein pakt für den rechtsstaat und
digital pakt für justiz heißt doch nicht
der bund bezahlt die ländern das
justizpersonal das ist doch ein völliges
missverständnis es geht um fundamentale
modernisierung und verbesserung
verbesserung des rechtsstaates ist
richtig dass die länder auch eine
eigenverantwortung übernehmen genau an
dieser stelle höhere steuereinnahmen als
der bund verantwortung für die eigene
justiz sondern biete ich doch darum dass
wir uns da ehrlich machen an der stelle
und diese verantwortung auch von den
bundesländer vielmehr übernommen wird
als bisher es braucht eine gemeinsame
anstrengung ich gucke nach hessen mein
eigenes bundesland wo die einführung der
e akte jetzt leider etliche jahre nach
hinten nach hinten gerutscht ist auch
diese anspringen wir stehen zu unserer
verantwortung als bunt aber es geht
nicht darum dass wir nur den ländern das
personal bezahle freundin kolleginnen
und kollegen
zweites thema möchte ich an der stelle
und das ist sehr viel ernster natürlich
nochmal ansprechen klare vision
sicherlich viele hier in dem hause den
vergangenen wochen und monaten viel mit
unmittelbar betroffenen mit geflüchteten
unter ukraine auch häufiger mit unseren
generalkonsul in hessen zur situation in
der ukraine gesprochen die erzählungen
aus den kriegsgebieten machen unfassbar
betroffen bilder und erzählungen von
denen meine generation glaubte die
finden wir in geschichtsbüchern die
sehen wir ein schwarz weiß filmen sind
realität in die auf diesem kontinent
sind an der tagesordnung das erschüttert
und wenn ich das wenn ich 30 jahre
zurückdenke wie wahnsinnig unterscheidet
sich das von der aufbruchstimmung in
europa 1989 1990 nein liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen diesen krieg der seit 99
tagen in europa tobt und der uns alle
erschüttert den dürfen werde ich zur
tagesordnung werden lassen deswegen sind
und bleiben wir an der seite der ukraine
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen vielen
dank
[Applaus]
dr michael spricht für die afg
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube obwohl wir in der afg
jetzt nicht so die größten fans dieser
rot magenta grüne regierung sind haben
wir den etat des bundesministeriums für
justiz dennoch unsere zustimmung erteilt
warum ganz einfach dieser etat ist einer
der wenigen haushalte der tatsächlich
einnahmen im nennenswerten umfang
generiert und der mit dem ihm zur
verfügung gestellten mitteln auch sehr
ordentlich haushalten allerdings in den
beratungen wurde angedeutet dass sich
der personalbedarf in zukunft erhöhen
könnte und da kann ich ihnen jetzt schon
mal versprechen dass wir dann natürlich
sehr genau hinschauen werden wir sind
für einen schlanken staat eine optimale
nutzung der ressourcen und natürlich für
größtmögliche abbau von bürokratie
[Applaus]
insofern freue ich mich dass wir uns
gemeinsam mit dem bundesrechnungshof und
dem bmj darauf verständigen konnte das
vor der schaffung neuer stellen im
bundesamt für justiz erst mal eine
ordentliche personal bedarfsanalyse
stehen soll ich denke das ist auch die
mindestanforderung bevor man überhaupt
daran denken sollte den steuerzahler
noch mehr zu belasten
einige neue stellen wurden allerdings
auch mit diesem haushalt schon
geschaffen und zwar beim
generalbundesanwalt
bei der fdp wollte man schon zu beginn
des ukraine kriegs gegen russland
ermitteln so dass die forderungen nach
mehr stellen dort recht früh auftauchen
anfangs fand ich das einfach nur
populistisch und mir war das auch ein
bisschen zu billig dass man hier aus dem
schrecken des krieges kapital in form
von politischen haltungsnoten schlagen
wollte doch dann ging der krieg weiter
und wir wurden mit den schrecklichen
bildern aus buchschlag konfrontiert man
hatte da noch gar nicht wenn man hatte
das noch gar nicht verdaut da ging auch
schon der informationskrieg beider
seiten muss um die frage wer denn für
dieses massaker verantwortlich sein
medial war die sache sehr schnell klar
aber im internet fanden und finden sich
immer noch die verschiedensten theorien
und wildesten spekulationen über dieses
verbrechen und von diesem hintergrund
wird einmal mehr die bedeutung
transparenter rechtsstaatlicher
verfahren klar in der jüngeren
geschichte haben wir bei dem sogenannten
massaker von rack
1999 erlebt wie mittels einer
polarisierten berichterstattung der
dieser vorfall politisch
instrumentalisiert und im zuge der
internationalen empörung dann zur
legitimation für den eintritt der nato
in den kosovo krieg wurde bis zum
bis dato ist klar was gott eigentlich
genau passiert ist zahlreiche
ermittlungen kam zu widersprüchlichen
ergebnissen
wir wissen heute dass es dieses massaker
höchstwahrscheinlich nie gegeben hat
dafür aber eine vielzahl an
falschinformationen fake nußdorf durch
rechtsstaatliche ermittlung wissen wie
heute aber auch dass es vier jahre zuvor
das massaker von srebrenica im juli 1995
tatsächlich gegeben hat nach dem fall
der wohin schutzzone in scream kalten
dort 7000 menschen lediglich erst einmal
als verschwunden die internationale
gemeinschaft war anfangs eher träge als
es darum ging herauszufinden was da
passiert ist erste berichte über die
geschehnisse wurden zunächst als gerücht
abgetan das mag auch damit
zusammenhängen dass sich die vereinten
nationen bis heute dem vorwurf
ausgesetzt sehen dass ihre schutztruppen
ins kritiker eine mitschuld an dem
massaker abtragen nach weiteren
ermittlungen wurde das ganze grauen was
sich dort ereignet hatte schließlich
offenbar bosnisch serbische armee
angehörige und paramilitärische truppen
haben systematisch 8000 männliche
bosniaken von ihren frauen kindern
müttern und schwestern getrennt und
anschließend bei massenexekutionen ohne
viel federlesens erschossen danach um
die toten einfach in massengräbern
verscharrt heute wissen wir was wahr ist
und was nicht wir verfügen über das
wissen über ein massaker das wollen die
stattgefunden hat ebenso über das wissen
über ein massaker was durch die un
kriegsverbrechertribunal zu recht als
völkermord eingestuft nur unabhängige
objektive ermittlungen versetzen uns in
die lage wahrheit von fiktion zu trennen
und nur red
und nur rechtsstaatliche verfahren
versetzen uns in die lage auf basis von
fakten
verantwortliche zu identifizieren und
sie dann zur rechenschaft zu dieser
aufwand und diese sorgfalt schulden wir
auch den todesopfern von butscher und
deswegen ist es auch richtig dem
generalbundesanwalt bei seinen struktur
ermittlungsverfahren mit zusätzlichen
stellen zu unterstützen danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
michael espendiller für die afg hat noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass in der tat
zwei neue stellen besetzt werden sollen
beim generalbundesanwalt den bezug zum
krieg in der ukraine stehen soll oder
draußen hell lobby sein da rennt schon
jemand ist noch nicht gewählt haben dann
sollten sie das jetzt schritte tun
gleichwohl gebe ich dem kollegen devise
das wort für die spd fraktion
darauf hingewiesen dass die neuerliche
abstimmung unter anderem zur richtung
zum bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt
gleich eingestellt werden der krise
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
ist belegt wenn den rechtsstaat der
bundesrepublik deutschland diskutieren
den haushalt des
bundesjustizministeriums diskutieren wer
diese debatte dafür verwendet
gräueltaten kriegsverbrechen zu
relativieren wird putins angriffskrieg
hier verteidigt wer sich zum
verlängerten arm von desinformation
macht das ist einfach nur schäbig und
zeigt euch geistesblitze
kolleginnen und kollegen der 24 zweiter
der völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg
von wladimir putin auf die ukraine hat
noch mal eins deutlich gemacht es gilt
die stärke des rechts und nicht das
recht des stärkeren
es ist wichtig dass wir einen
funktionierenden rechtsstaat haben einen
rechtsstaat haben der aufklärt ein
rechtsstaat diebe haben der auch
wehrhaft ist und ein rechtsstaat haben
der auch und der vorschriften bei uns in
unserem strafgesetzen dafür sorgt dass
kriegsverbrechen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden und ich bin dankbar dass
diese strukturermittlungen bei uns
stattfinden um aufzuklären um klar
schwarz auf weiß zu sagen was da
stattgefunden hat um solche
verschwörungstheorien einer zu bieten
[Applaus]
ich begrüße es daher ausdrücklich dass
wir gerade im personal aus haushalt des
bundesjustizministeriums beim
generalbundesanwalt zusätzliche stellen
haben und ich bin auch dankbar dass wir
es immer wieder über diesen haushalt auf
den weg bringen institutionen der uno
der internationalen gericht zur für die
übrigens immer wieder auch von russland
blockiert worden sind dass wir diese
letztendlich auch immer wieder stärken
ist als bundesrepublik deutschland hier
letztendlich auch unserer verantwortung
gerecht werden und hier daran
beteiligten dass das was da passiert
aufgeklärt wird und das ist der ansatz
den wir auch weiter verfolgen und dem
wir den bundeshaushalt auch unterstützen
das ist der richtige weg liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lassen sie mich
auch einsatz ganz deutlich auch sagen
eine der größten herausforderungen die
wir für unsere demokratie haben ist der
kampf gegen den wachsenden
rechtsextremismus gegen den rechts
terrorismus in unserem land und ich sage
das ganz deutlich herr brandner hat ja
mittlerweile die debatte verlassen
erscheint mittagspause zu machen anstatt
sein
der ältestenrat hinrunde gewesen herr
brand in mettmann hat und hat sich
entschuldigt das ist es nicht
dann nehme ich das zurück dass er nicht
da ist aber ich sage mal ganz deutlich
das was er ein kritik an heiko maas
gesagt hat an katarina barley und
christina lambrecht völlig falsch diese
drei bundesminister der justiz haben
einen klaren kompass es ist der kampf
gegen rechtsextremismus gegen
verfassungsfeinde in diesem land und wer
schon probleme hat mit dem
verfassungsschutz in der eigenen partei
den wundert mich nicht dass er das
britische anzumerken hat
für uns ist es relativ klar dass wir
gegen hass und hetze vorgehen wollen
hass und hetze kann letztendlich dazu
finden wir haben es leider wieder in den
vergangenen jahren gesehen dass daraus
auch taten folgen dar und es ist richtig
hier vorzugehen hier die entsprechenden
punkte auf den weg zu bringen und das
ist auch das was wir uns als
ampelkoalition verein vereinbart haben
wir als ampelkoalition haben in unserem
koalitionsvertrag wichtige punkte in der
rechtspolitik aufgeschrieben wichtige
punkte auch in der innenpolitik
aufgeschrieben und es ist gott sei dank
nicht mehr so wie in den vergangenen
jahren und ich merke dass er bei der
union dass dieses schubladendenken immer
noch vorherrscht nein wir arbeiten
zusammen in der rechts und innenpolitik
für einen modernen staat für einen
modernen rechtsstaat für modernität in
der innenpolitik in der
einwanderungspolitik und da arbeiten wir
als bundesinnenministerium als
bundesjustizministerium zusammen und
dann bin ich im bundesjustizminister
marco buschmann als auch der
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser
wirklich dankbar da passt kein blatt
dazwischen und wir bringen diese
reformvorhaben die wir uns verabredet
haben auch auf den weg liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
[Applaus]
wir werden auch als ampelkoalition die
vorhaben auf die wir uns verständigt
haben auch sehr zügig auf den weg
bringen ich begrüße es ausdrücklich dass
wir noch vor der sommerpause gerade im
bereich des 219 a strafgesetzbuch das
auf den weg bringen was wir als
ampelkoalition uns darauf verständigt
damit ist ein wichtiges erstes signal
was hier vorangeht denn wir haben viele
themen die
gesellschaftspolitisch in den
vergangenen jahren nicht angegangen
worden sind die nicht vorangebracht
worden sind die übrigens von der union
diskreditiert werden wie die
verantwortungsgemeinschaft wo menschen
füreinander verantwortung übernehmen und
menschen etwas bekommen dass sie
rechtssicherheit haben für regelung mit
die getroffen werden müssen dass das
auch noch diskreditiert werden das kann
nicht sein und da ist es wichtig dass
wir uns als ampelkoalition ihr modell
auf den weg gemacht habe und dieses land
voranbringen und einiges verstaubte was
in 16 jahren union nicht möglich war
endlich auf den weg bringen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie mich auch ein satz sagen wie wichtig
es ist im ampel koalitionsvertrag dass
wir auch immer wieder dafür sorgen die
demokratie in unserem land zu stärken
dass wir gegen die feinde der demokratie
auch vorgeben darum ist es gut dass wir
als ampelkoalition uns darauf
verständigt haben die demokratischen
initiativen in unserem land zu stärken
sie zu fördern sie zu unterstützen denn
sie sind es täglich die sich vor ort für
die demokratie einsetzen die dafür
sorgen dass diese demokratie wehrhaft
ist und darum ist es gut dass wir
gemeinsam in dieser bundesregierung auch
ein demokratie oder gesetz auf den weg
bringen werden und das auch relativ
zügig wie wir es im ampel
koalitionsvertrag auch geredet haben
dann lassen sie mich lieben kolleginnen
am schluss noch auf einen punkt eingehen
wollen uns eint der kampf gegen diese
schrecklichen taten die wir diese woche
wieder erlebt haben und wir haben noch
in der großen koalition immer wieder
auch geschaut was wir tun können wie wir
den tätern hand papa werden können und
da werden wir auch die vorschläge
gemeinsam mit justizministerium
innenministerium auch vorliegen aber
mehr kinderschutz wirklich will und sich
verweigert kinderrechte ins grundgesetz
zu schreiben der ist nicht glaubwürdig
das ist etwas bringen sie da über ihren
schatten machen sie die
grundgesetzänderung mit dass
kinderrechte ins grundgesetz geschrieben
werden
der nächste gegner hier in der debatte
über den einzelplan und sieben justiz
und bundesverfassungsgericht
der kommt noch nicht an den zunächst
eine mitteilung von kathrin egert das
ist nicht der fall dann schließe ich die
wahlen und bitte die schriftführerinnen
und schriftführer mit der auszählung zu
beginnen und ich gebe das wort dem
kollegen helge limburg für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die kunden also die wahl ist
beendet für den richter zum
bundesverfassungsgericht und helge
limburg rechtspolitischer sprecher der
bündnisgrünen erhält jetzt das wort
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wenn die waffen sprechen schweigt das
recht nicht auch im krieg gelten regeln
und gesetze die
russische armee verübt bei ihrem
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg nahezu
jedem straftatbestand der im
völkerstrafgesetzbuch aufgelistet ist
plünderungen verschleppungen
vergewaltigungen folter morde
die ukraine hat mit der strafrechtlichen
aufarbeitung begonnen aber das ist hier
schon mehrfach zu recht gesagt worden
auch in deutschland können diese
verbrechen nach dem weltrechtsprinzip
gehandelt werden um das sicherzustellen
stärken wir in der tat mit diesem
haushalt den bereich des
völkerstrafrechts beim
generalbundesanwalt das ist ein
wichtiger schritt
[Applaus]
wir dürfen hier nicht stehen bleiben er
steht zu befürchten dass dieser krieg
war eine weile andauern wird und da
müssen wir sicherstellen dass menschen
die aus der ukraine zu uns fliehen und
vielleicht beweismittel haben
augenzeugenberichte handyvideos
ähnliches dass diese auch wissen wo sie
die hinterlegen können dass wir
informationskampagnen mal zu uns
angebote auch in der fläche und
riskantes haben und wir müssen die inter
zahlt zusammenarbeit der justiz weiter
stärken so wie es der justizminister
angekündigt hat dazu gehört es zum
beispiel strukturen zu schaffen das
verfahrensunterlagen urteile und
ähnliches aus dem völkerstrafrecht nicht
nur jetzt ukraine strafverfahren sondern
von anderen völker strafverfahren die ja
gerade auch laufen in deutschland dass
die auch zeitnah übersetzt werden damit
sie der internationale justiz helfen
können und anderen verfahren zur
verfügung stehen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe die erwartung ich gehe davon
aus dass in diesem sommer der ukraine
der status als beitrittskandidat zur
europäischen union zuerkannt werden wird
die zeit ist reif dafür
und das wird dann auch konsequenzen im
bereich der justiziellen zusammenarbeit
haben wir sollten schon jetzt mit den
planungen beginnen wie wir den den
aufbau den geordneten aufbau der justiz
in der ukraine während oder nach
hoffentlich dann bald nach dem krieg mit
unterstützen können wir die justizieller
und polizeilicher zusammenarbeit mit der
ukraine ausbauen können liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau präsidentin ist es heute zu recht
mehrfach gesagt worden bemerkenswerter
weise von den räten aller demokratischen
fraktionen nur die fraktion ganz rechts
hat diesen umstand
völlig außer acht gelassen sie werden
wissen warum heute jährt sich der
rechtsextreme mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
dieser mord hat uns alle erschüttert
unsere gedanken sind bei den angehörigen
aber bei erschütterungen gab es eben
nicht bleiben und deshalb ist es auch
gut dass wir den bereich der ermittlung
gegen rechts terrorismus beim
generalbundesanwalt haushalterisch
stärken herzlichen dank insbesondere
auch an die haushälterin haushälter
dafür
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zur
justiz in diesem land gehören nicht nur
richter und staatsanwälte staatsanwälte
rechtsanwältin sondern natürlich auch
viele weitere berufsgruppen und auch
ehrenamtliche im kommenden jahr finden
die schöffen wahlen statt und leider gab
es in der vergangenheit immer wieder
schwierigkeiten dieses wichtige amt zu
besetzen deswegen sind wir dem schiffen
verband sehr dankbar dass er angeboten
hat eine kampagne an
informationskampagne zu organisieren und
auch hier ist es gut dass wir im
haushalt den nötigen mittel
bereitstellen auch da herzlichen dank an
die haushälterin 1000
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auch wenn
es in der tat teilweise aus den reihen
der union anders klingt aber rechtsstaat
bedeutet doch nicht immer neue
überwachungsinstrumente zu erfinden ins
bundesgesetzblatt zu schreiben und dann
zu hoffen dass vielleicht einen teil
davon nach der verknüpfung durch keil
oder europäische gerichte noch übrig
bleibt das ist doch nicht der
rechtsstaat so haben sie es in den
letzten 16 jahren gemacht ich hätte
verstanden wenn die fortschritts
koalition dafür kritisiert worden wäre
dass wir in der tat mehr entwicklungs
und einige befugnisse schaffen wollen
mit quick freeze mehr als gegenwärtig
eher als vorhanden ist wie sie wissen
die vorzeichnung zwar im blatt steht
aber eigentlich angewandt wird das ist
doch die realität sie reiten hier ein
lange verstorbenes wert immer noch
verzweifelt durch die manege beteiligen
sich doch an den debatten darüber wie
wir über was sondermaßnahmen
rechtsstaatlich durchsetzen können und
nicht debatten der vergangenheit zurück
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
beraten in der tat auch den etat des
bundesverfassungsgerichts mit dass der
ist haushalterisch unspektakulär aber
das ändert nichts an der großen
bedeutung dieses gerichts ein bereich in
dem es in den vergangenen jahren leider
besonders deutlich tätig werden muss ist
die frage der gleichstellung
homosexueller paare sehenden auges hat
es die union und der kollegin lisa zu
recht darauf hingewiesen hingenommen
dass sie immer nur dann reagiert haben
wenn karlsruhe sie dazu bezogen hat
allein sechs urteile zeugen davon mit
dieser haltung muss schluss sein wir
wollen nicht warten bis karlsruhe zb die
gleichstellung von kindern erzwingt den
queeren partnerschaften hineingeboren
werden wir werden als gesetzgeber aktiv
werden und wir wollen in der tat alle
kinder die ihre parolen gegen ein
geboren werden gleich stellen das sind
wir den kindern tatsächlich schuldig
liebe kollegen
die nächste rednerin für die cdu csu
fraktion ist die kollegen nicht doktor
sondern winkelmeier-becker dieser
patrick mayer bag
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn der haushalt des
bundesjustizministeriums beraten wird
dann kann der finanzminister eigentlich
entspannen hätte also auch hier bleiben
können denn es ist der haushalt mit den
längsten ausgaben aber wir haben auch so
gehört es geht eigentlich auch noch mehr
geld die größte einzelne ausgabe dieser
wahlperiode wird wahrscheinlich wieder
im kontext des pakts für den rechtsstaat
rechtsstaat erfolgen so wie es eben die
erste auflage in der letzten wahlperiode
gegeben hat
220 millionen genau das wird nicht im
justiz haushalt statt bin jedenfalls war
es beim ersten mal so
aber 220 millionen die über den weg der
steuerverteilung zwischen bund und
ländern diesen zu schließen deshalb ist
es auch gestern noch nicht angelegt im
justiz haushalten nicht erkennbar aber
es wäre eben sehr sehr gut dass wir eben
und setzte schon verständigen dass wir
das alle unterstützen wir hatten es auch
im wahlprogramm
denn die länder brauchen diese
unterstützen wir wissen alle dass es
eigentlich die aufgabe der länder ist
aber hier gibt es eben einen großen
nachholbedarf und wir wollen das gerne
auch mit ihnen zusammen zu handeln und
unterstützen die länder sollten zeitlich
wissen womit sie da rechnen können
um ausrüstung von den sitzungssälen so
wie wir das auch in anspruch nehmen bei
verhandlungen oder anhörungen dass wir
eben auch sachverständige mal zu
schreiten können es geht um die
digitalisierung der grund wie ich ein
ganz wichtiger punkt zum beispiel auch
in der steigerung der effizienz von
geldwäsche und es geht um die bessere
ausrüstung der stadt und schafften damit
sie unterstützt werden in ihrer
richtigen
ermittlungstätigkeit
nehmen mit unseren regelungen hier auch
verantwortung für die justiz haushalte
der länder
indem wir das materielle recht gestalten
und natürlich auch das verfahrensrecht
und da gibt uns zu denken dass im moment
der und dass der deutsche richterbund
wirklich allein schlägt ihn sagt dass
wir eine zunehmende anzahl von
massenverfahren haben die wirklich die
richterschaft an die belastungsgrenze
bringt was die arbeitsfähigkeit was gilt
und damit natürlich auch ein
vertrauensverlust in die
funktionsfähigkeit der justiz
in richtung wunsch legt auch konkrete
maßnahmen
vornehmlich hier vorab
entscheidungsverfahren beim
revisionsgericht
einzuführen oder eben auch vorgaben zu
machen für die struktur für die struktur
von schriftsätzen die eben häufig nur
noch aus textbausteinen bestehen die gar
nichts mit dem konkreten fall zu tun
haben das sind die themen mit denen sich
auch aktuell justizminister konferenz
beschäftigen und damit müssen auch wir
uns dringend beschäftigen da der lässt
der vorschlag zur umsetzung der eben
verbandsklage richtlinie noch auf sich
warten
in diesem jahr noch beschlossen werden
muss
und zwar bei der ersten auflage nämlich
der verabschiedung der muster
feststellungsklage wichtig dass hier
eine qualifizierte verbände ganz unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen nur diese
klagen führen dürfen es ist gut dass das
offenbar auch sie überzeugt hat und dass
wir daran festhalten wollen ich möchte
aber an regen hatten damals eine sehr
gute sachverständigenanhörung mit nach
etlichen guten konstruktiven vorschlägen
zum beispiel einen eröffnungsbeschluss
über die vielen fragen der zulässigkeit
der klage
einzel einzurichten das ist ein wirklich
guter hinweis gewesen wir könnten das
damals unter dem zeitdruck wir wollten
ja noch rechtzeitig mit dieser klage
aber das gesetz bekommen damit die diese
verfahren noch dieses verfahren nutzen
konnten und nicht mehr fristen unter dem
damaligen zeit druck konnten wir das
nicht mehr und
ich möchte in diesen tagen
auch einen blick nach warschau richten
wir fahren mit dem rechtsausschuss in
der kommenden woche dorthin es ist
spannend in diesen tagen zu sehen dass
die eu kommissionspräsidenten dort ist
sie nutzen zum ersten mal dass die
europäische ebene mit geld auch einfluss
nehmen kann und das rechtfertigt sich
daraus was das thema der unabhängigkeit
der justiz weil dies zu den assets zu
den kernforderungen auch der
europäischen rechtsordnung gehört und es
ist gut dass sie das mit der
rückendeckung auch des europäischen
gerichtshofs machen kann
[Applaus]
so lässt sich dass die europäische union
die auszahlung von etwa 36 milliarden
euro davon abhängig macht dass in
unserem nachbarland die justiz wieder
mehr zur unabhängigkeit zurückkehren
kann ich denke wir haben in der nächsten
woche die möglichkeit ins darüber zu
informieren und das vielleicht auch noch
mit ein bisschen rückenwind zu
unterstützen dass die unabhängigkeit
dort auch wieder hergestellt werden
ganz zum schluss möchte ich noch einen
anderen punkt ansprechen und zwar wir
machen hier rechtspolitik und ich glaube
es ist unsere aufgabe auch uns die
wichtigen in die wichtigsten
diskussionen dieser wahlperiode auch mit
einzubringen und dazu zählt sicherlich
das thema klimaschutz energiewende
transformation der industrie und ich
denke da haben wir auch als
rechtspolitiker sehr konstruktives
beizutragen wenn es sind doch gerade
auch große rechtsfragen die hier im raum
stehen dann das klima urteil das
bundesverfassungsgericht
wir haben klagen gegen unternehmen die
zu mehr klimaschutz aufgefordert werden
wir haben die vielen hürden die vielen
rechtlichen hürden die immer wieder
angemahnt werden und die im weg stehen
wenn es darum geht eben morgen die tat
zu schreiben und die klimawende
umzusehen deshalb denke ich während eine
gute idee wenn wir uns auch initiative
setzt einmal mit allen facetten
beschäftigen würden im refugium und das
dann auch einzubringen in die fach
politik ich habe 100 dass die koalition
da und wie das bedeutet das machen aber
kollegin und mal drüber ist wäre vor
gewitter zu kommen
nun ja ich wähle die rechtspolitische
sprecherin der spd hat jetzt gleich das
wort
und
und danach meine damen und herren werde
ich ihn nur einen kleinen programm
hinweis geben aber bleiben sie dran das
folgt dann nach frau ich wähle
naja der frau präsidentin sehr geehrter
herr bundesminister buschmann werte
kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktion technisch
gesprochen beraten wir heute über den
haushalt des einzelplan 10 7 tatsächlich
aber reden wir über sehr viel mehr wir
reden über das rückgrat unserer
demokratie über rechtsstaatlichkeit und
justiz über ordnung und regeln die wir
in unserem land der willkür in vielen
anderen orten der welt entgegen setzen
die wir hass und hingegen gesetzen die
wir rechtlich bekämpfen müssen wir reden
über die durchsetzung des rechts jeden
einzelnen und dass wir unserem land
dafür sorgen dass derjenige der recht
hat auch recht bekommt
wir wissen dass ohne ein
funktionierendes rückgrat ist keinen
aufrechten gang gibt und wir wissen dass
wir ohne einen starken rechtsstaat keine
funktionierende demokratie haben von
daher ist es hier und heute auch sehr
sehr wichtig nochmals zu betonen dass
wir gerade vom anbetracht der
weltpolitischen lage und putins
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine neben all
den außen- und sicherheitspolitischen
maßnahmen die wir eingegangen sind die
wir machen wo wir handeln auch eben
unseren rechtsstaat stärken und schützen
müssen und zwar stärken in dieser
debatte insbesondere mit soliden
finanzen und gutem stellenaufbau
in den haushaltsverhandlungen der
letzten woche sind dazu auch im
bundeshaushalt neben der guten vorlage
des ministeriums auch noch einige
wichtige schwerpunkte gesetzt worden es
wurde heute häufig angesprochen
insbesondere die personelle verstärkung
des generalbundesanwalts und die
gezielte stärkung im bereich der
struktur ermittlungsverfahren die
bereits laufen wo es unglaublich wichtig
ist dass wir gerade heute eben die
kriegsverbrechen die zurzeit in der
ukraine verübt werden aufdecken und
ermitteln und nach dem weltrechtsprinzip
in deutschland eben auch verfolgen das
urteil des oberlandesgerichts koblenz zu
kriegsverbrechen in syrien hat weltweit
aufsehen erregt und wirklich ein vorbild
charakter der deutschen justiz in europa
und weltweit gezeigt ist es wichtig dass
gerade wir als bundesrepublik
deutschland tier weltweit eine
vorreiterrolle einnehmen in anbetracht
unserer geschichte ist es umso wichtiger
meine sehr verehrten kolleginnen und
kollegen
und neben der stärkung des
generalbundesanwalts ist es auch wichtig
natürlich ins inland zu schauen es ist
wichtig dass der bundesjustizminister
gesagt hat dass er in gesprächen mit den
ländern dass die justizministerkonferenz
gesagt hat dass sie bereit sind für
einen weiteren pakt für den rechtsstaat
für eine verstetigung des pakts für den
rechtsstaat den wir dringend brauchen
natürlich können wir hier als und nicht
die kompetenzen und aufgaben der länder
alleine wahrnehmen was wir aber machen
müssen ist strukturell zu helfen ist
beim personal und bei der
digitalisierung unter die arme zu
greifen denn wir haben die zahlen gehört
wir haben in der justiz eine
pensionierungswelle die bevorsteht dem
müssen wir entgegenwirken aber nicht nur
bei den richterinnen und richtern
sondern auch im unterbau insbesondere
kann ich aus meiner zeit in der justiz
berichten dass gerade in den
geschäftsstellen die arbeitsüberlastung
enorm ist und wie hier auch die
arbeitnehmerinnen rechte stärken müssen
wir können unsere justiz nicht auf ihrem
rücken aufbauen sondern müssen sie
entlasten und hierfür weitere stellen
sorgen
zudem werden wir nicht nur im übrigen
als selbsternannte fortschritts
koalition sondern auch als beschriebene
fortschritts koalition aufgrund einfach
eine sehr sehr guten koalitionsvertrages
gerade im bereich der justiz in der
digitalisierung sehr viel vornehmen wir
werden unseren rechtsstaat moderner
machen wir werden von den gürteltieren
mehr zur akte kommen wir werden gucken
wie die einzelnen bundesländer brücken
zwischen den unterschiedlichen systemen
die sich entwickelt haben bei der e akte
herstellen können damit informationen
die ausgetauscht werden müssen können
auch tatsächlich ausgetauscht werden und
wie effektiv zusammenarbeiten in der
justiz in deutschland
obwohl der haushalt des
justizministeriums überwiegend einen
personal haushalt ist gibt es aber auch
wichtige projekte die gefördert werden
da möchte ich insbesondere auf eines
aufmerksam machen und dies mit einem
appell verbinden der kollege helge
limburg hat es bereits angesprochen im
nächsten jahr stehen in deutschland die
schöffen wahlen an die schöffen werden
gewählt für die jahre vier und zwei und
2024 bis 2028
die
informationskampagne des deutschen
schützenbundes wird dazu beitragen dass
mehr leute auf dieses wichtige amt
aufmerksam gemacht werden was in
deutschland leider in der öffentlichkeit
nicht so bekannt ist wie in amerika zum
beispiel die jury aber in der justiz
brauchen wir schöpfen wir brauchen
laienrichter um überhaupt eine effektive
justiz zu haben und um auch die
perspektive der bevölkerung in den
urteilen verankern zu können deshalb
sehr verehrte damen und herren
erkundigen sie sich bewerben sie sich
bei ihren kommunen als schöpfen wir
brauchen welche die insbesondere den
rechtsstaat in ihrem herzen tragen die
vielleicht auch interesse haben ein
clubheim
podcasts oder gerichtssendungen die
möglicherweise heute wurde es häufiger
angesprochen gern das neo magazin royal
gucken und es sind interessante
nachricht ist dass jan böhmermann einer
der bekanntesten deutschen schaffen ist
aber insbesondere leute die ebenso die
justiz stärken sich einbringen und eben
entsprechend bewerben vielen dank für
diesen einsatz
zum schluss zum schluss möchte ich
insbesondere den haushältern für diesen
guten haushalt diese tolle vorlage für
die spd fraktion ist da die gedanken und
freue mich über die weiteren beratungen
wir können diesen entwurf sehr gut und
gerne zustimmen
meine damen und herren während der
bundestag habe der einzelplan 7 justiz
und bundesverfassungsgericht debattiert
und wir werden auch hier bleiben möchte
ich ihnen dennoch ans herz legen heute
treffen sich auch die
ministerpräsidenten hier in berlin um 15
uhr wenn sie gemeinsam mit dem kanzler
zusammenkommen vorher sind sie schon
gemeinsam zusammengetreten und es geht
um die form des medien staatsvertrages
und wer das verfolgen möchte der kann in
den nächsten minuten die pressekonferenz
ist glaube ich für 14 05 10 angesetzt
meistens wird paar minuten später werden
der kann also in den nächsten minuten zu
hbbtv wechseln das ist die rote taste
meistens auf ihrer fernbedienung wenn
das ihr fernseher hier gibt dann können
sie parallel hier sozusagen die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bei phoenix
erleben hier im hauptprogramm aber
bleiben wir hier im bundestag und jetzt
kommt glaube ich gerade das ergebnis
nein kommt nicht das ergebnis okay jetzt
geht es aber gleich weiter hier im
bereich justiz und
bundesverfassungsgericht einzelplan 07
über den jetzt schon die ganze zeit
diskutiert wird mit tobias matthias
peterka er ist von der afg und sitzt im
ausschuss für recht und
verbraucherschutz
tobias peter hat das wort für die a-elf
gehen
[Applaus]
auf den namen
frau präsidentin werte kollegen und
gäste wenn wir schon beim klarstellen
sind möchte ich hier betonen dass bei
kollege aston villa in keiner weise
kriegsverbrechen geleugnet hat er hat
auch international ermittlungen
hingewiesen dass es genau das gegenteil
davon
zum haushalt die schuldenbremse und die
entsprechenden turnübungen drumherum die
stehen derzeit bei uns hier im
rampenlicht der justiz haushalt ist da
nicht prägend wenn man den sonst
üblichen kategorien der ampel zumindest
folgt die fdp als zumindest nicht per se
links liegt mir ja bekanntlich besonders
am herzen beziehungsweise deren projekte
innerhalb der koalition da lasse ich mir
persönlich dann sogar einige argumente
zur liberalisierung der beratung von
schwangeren erzählen problematisch
wird's aber dann wenn solche
schaufenster projekte bei genauerem
hinsehen das ganze repertoire ausmachen
beginnen auszumachen beginnen und was
ist mit weniger glanzvollen projekten
die aber dann kostenintensiver sind wie
es wurde während der pakt für den
rechtsstaat der so laut
koalitionsvertrag verfestigt werden und
die justiz haushalt waren mal 500
millionen angedacht die fehlen
vorliegend fast komplett kommen die noch
vielleicht irgendwo anders untergebracht
in einem sonderhaushalt ist ja derzeit
in mode bei uns und die pensionswelle
wird die justiz jedenfalls mit schwung
treffen vor gebaut wurde nichts sagen
auch die landesminister und da brauche
ich nicht erst einmal die klagewelle zu
den corona gängelungen und in
asylverfahren anbringen um zu zeigen
dass dies zu einem kafkaesken
staatsversagen führen wird
wahrscheinlich kommen sie herr minister
dann mit der ausrede um die ecke das ja
nun immerhin nicht mehr gegen kürzungen
von al g2 geklagt werden muss weil die
kürzungen haben sie abgeschafft bravo
damit untergraben sie vielmehr gleich in
zweierlei hinsicht das vertrauen der
bürger nämlich in den rechtsstaat ohne
den sozialstaat
der erhebliche eingriffe in
privatwirtschaftliche unternehmen durch
die wissel blogger umsetzung die wird
übrigens auch zu vielen prozessen führen
sie ja buschmann wollen da zwar keine
wachsweichen ethik tatbestände ok jedoch
weitgehend nationales recht gleich
einklagbar mit einbeziehen und das ist
mir zu sehr durchgemogelt das ist den
kuchen haben und essen wollen
warum auch teil der lösung sein wenn man
in der ampel gemütlich mitschwimmen kann
bisschen empörung über
vorratsdatenspeicherung
vogelwilde lebensgemeinschaft gmbhs
erfinden und vielleicht dann auch gleich
das ganze strafrecht zu einem
frankenstein konstrukt um moden
schwarzwald und sonstiger
leistungsbetrug passt scho
meinungsäußerungen ohne güte stempel
buschmann sofort zugriff
konsequent bleiben sie immerhin dass sie
bei der boom iq digital teilnehmen und
uns hier mit ihrer präsenz beehren
technik demonstration unter umständen
erfolgreich inhalte jeweils mehr als
fraglich vielen dank
zu meinem und herren ich wollte noch mal
kurz aufklären klarer am binger von der
linken die rechtspolitische sprecherin
hatte von geredet da gab es einen
zwischenruf der afg sie wolle menschen
gewalt antun und martin reichert und
enrico comic haben einen ordnungsruf
kassierte von katrin göring eckardt die
mittlerweile weg gegangen ist und durch
übersetzt
jetzt geht's hier weiter mit charmant
bayram für die bündnis krieg
wir beraten hier gemeinsam den haushalt
der justiz und ich freue mich sehr dass
wir
deutlich nicht nur von unserer
perspektive aus feststellen können
sondern auch von außen betrachtet
feststellen können das was hier die
fortschritts koalition auf den weg
gebracht hat ist in zahlen gegossene
zukunftspolitik meine damen und
und ehrlich gesagt ich habe allen reden
zugehört und habe keine kritik
feststellen können die
gerechtfertigt in dem sinne wäre dass
sie substantiiert wäre und deswegen will
ich die mal einzeln durchgehen ich war
bei dem gespräch mit der italienischen
justiz ministerien junis
justizministerin ebenfalls dabei und ich
muss tatsächlich sagen es beeindruckt
mich sehr
wie italien bei der einziehung bei dem
umgang mit den sanktionen gegen die
oligarchen vorgeht aber liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der cdu
dass sie gerade sich hier hinstellen und
behaupten sie hätten da ideen gehabt in
den letzten 16 jahren wie man es besser
machen kann das erstaunt mich dann doch
wo sich ehrlich sagen aber ich muss auch
ganz klar sagen ich arbeite mit allen
demokratischen fraktionen zusammen
solange es darum geht lösungen zu finden
und ich freue mich auf ihre anträge die
uns dann im nächsten
rechtsausschuss beschäftigen werden und
ich freue mich wenn die dann so sind
dass man sie auch tatsächlich
mehrheitlich abstimmen kann
andere punkt der hier immer wieder
angesprochen wurde und wo ich irgendwie
wirklich mich sehr darüber freue dass es
uns gelungen ist und dass wir demnächst
die beratungen hier abschließen werden
ist die entkriminalisierung die
liberalisierung und ich muss sagen bei
der legalisierung müssen wir noch ein
bisschen nachlegen im bereich der
entkriminalisierung wird es uns gelingen
den 219 a nun endlich in die
geschichtsbücher zu schreiben und aus
unserem strafgesetzbuch
herauszustreichen meine damen und herren
da haben wir eine wirklich gute
grundlage auf den weg gebracht bei der
liberalisierung ist es finde ich und das
hat auch heute die debatte gezeigt
dem
justizminister zu verdanken dass er
steht er steht auch bei allen angriffen
auf die bürgerinnen rechte das muss man
immer wieder betonen es geht nicht nur
darum was wir an neuen gesetzen hier
einbringe es geht auch darum was wir als
ampel gemeinsam an unsinnigen anträgen
aus der opposition ablegen meine damen
und herren dank der liebe herr buschmann
ihr rückgrat in diesem bereich da macht
es doch tatsächlich spaß gemeinsam
politik zu machen weil wir nämlich
gezwungen sind mit an unseren
unterschiedlichen perspektiven immer
wieder und das werden die kolleginnen
und kollegen aus der ampel bestätigen zu
ringen um die antworten zu ringen um die
lösungen und manchmal auch unsere
eigenen
vorbehalte über bord zu werfen und damit
komme ich zu dem für mich in meinem
wahlkreis wichtigsten thema und ich
hätte mir gewünscht wir werden heute
schon einen schritt weiter aber eins ist
klar es kann nicht sein dass die cdu
immer noch legal alkohol konsumieren
darf und dass teile der menschen in
meinem wahlkreis dafür kriminalisiert
werden dass sie in ruhe prüfen wollen
das muss sich ändern und das kann nur
dieses parlament ändern wir brauchen die
legalisierung von cannabis denn eins ist
klar die prohibition
ist gescheitert sie ist gescheitert
meine damen und herren und wenn es eine
chance gibt dass diese fortschritts
koalition tatsächlich auch bei den
drogen bei der legalisierung von drogen
einen weg einschlägt der die
gesellschaftliche realität
abbildet dann muss ich ganz klar sagen
weil es mir aus verschiedenen
zusammenhängen zugetragen wurde ja auch
die konservativen sie gipfeln und
demnächst kiffen sie legal und das haben
sie dann uns zu verdanken
aber seien sie ganz beruhigt ich werde
es gerne
da wollte sie die zwischenfrage nicht
mehr das therapeutische heilmittel
cannabis hat übrigens ein cdu-minister
eingeführt nämlich hermann gröhe als
gesundheitsminister
kurzintervention von frau vogler
freue mich über ihr engagiertes plädoyer
für eine rasche freigabe von cannabis
würden sie an der stelle nicht auch
unterstützen wollen dass wir jetzt
möglichst schnell bevor das
entsprechende gesetzesvorhaben der ampel
koalition auch fertig ist zumindest mal
eine entkriminalisierung
durchsetzen damit nämlich nicht weiter
die käuferinnen und käufer in ihrem
wahlkreis verfolgt werden polizistinnen
und polizisten wertvolle arbeitszeit
justiz wertvolle arbeitszeit investieren
muss um diese völlig unsinnige und
kontraproduktive verfolgung von
cannabiskonsumenten und zu betreiben
liebe frau kollegin nicht nur als
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages
sondern als rechtsanwältin kann ich das
voll und ganz unterstützen und wir
arbeiten daran dass es so offen weg
gebracht wird das es rechtssicher vor
den gerichten standhält da vertraue ich
auf die entwürfe nicht nur des
bundesgesundheitsministers sondern auf
die
mitzeichnung des justizministers und ich
freue mich dass sie uns aber bei dem
anliegen sehr unterstützen wollen so
läuft das ganze werden sie teil der
fortschritts koalition fehlen meine
damen und herren ii sie jetzt zum joint
greifen will ich ihnen noch mal näher
bringen unser angebot für nichts extra
auf hbbtv
wenn sie eine rote taste an ihrem
fernsehgerät haben und die das mitmacht
dann drücken sie da jetzt drauf denn da
werden gleich die ministerpräsidenten
die sich heute in berlin treffen eine
pressekonferenz haben bevor sie dann
anschließend um 15 uhr zum kanzler denn
carsten müller jetzt für die cdu/csu
aber es ist schon merkwürdig dass das
spricht im grunde um gegen ihre beiträge
das ausschließlich sie sich als
fortschritts koalition bezeichnet
tatsächlich bei den schauen er weise sie
nämlich als eine agonie koalition was
erleben wir da machen wir das fest wir
schauen und den mantel manchmal der
vorgeblichen liberalität und stellen
dort doch eine ganz große portion
ideologie fest will einige beispiele
liefern haben es mit einer auftürmenden
corona welt zu tun anfang des jahres und
entgegen aller warnungen der zuständigen
fachminister auf bundes und landesebene
entscheidet sich diese bundesregierung
im übrigen maßgeblich getrieben durch
den fdp justizministern
dafür das infektionsschutzgesetz außer
kraft zu setzen und die bundesländer und
kommunen im stich zu lassen das ganze
setzt sich fort das ganze setzt sich
fort bei der es meiner sicht
unverantwortlichen nicht positionierung
der bundesregierung zur impfpflicht sie
haben damit dieses thema tatsächlich
umfangreich diskreditiert und vertrauen
in die politik nachhaltig zerstört wir
als union lassen ihnen das nicht zu
durchlebt
politisch wichtige und ernsthaft zu
führende debatten wie beispielsweise die
um § 209 10 a werden von mitgliedern der
fdp bundestagsfraktion mit skurrilen ja
geradezu albernen tanzeinlagen in
social-media-kanälen um meine damen und
herren das ist der ernsthaftigkeit des
themas nicht angemessen wir haben wir
haben uns heute
mehrfach über das thema sexuelle gewalt
gegen kinder unterhalten wir als union
wollen jeden
effektiven machbaren wirksam ansatz der
strafverfolgung realisiert wissen für
uns ist das thema
vorratsdatenspeicherung
kein leicht zu lösen es aber eins das
man angehen kann und ich halte es für
unverantwortlich wenn der fdp
justizminister mal eben so im
vorbeigehen von einem juristischen
zombie spricht das zeigt er hat das
thema nicht verstanden
meine damen und herren es
ist auch nicht schlüssig sozusagen hier
mit dem verweis auf vermeintliche
grundrechte anderer den schwächsten der
gesellschaft in schutz zu verweigern und
zwar dann wenn beispielsweise die fdp
nicht erst in dieser legislaturperiode
sondern schon in der letzten eine
inhaltskontrolle von kommunikation über
messenger kanäle das kriegen sie nicht
unter ein und denselben gut und mit der
union ist das nicht zu machen ist ein
willkürliches grundrechte verschwunden
ist und wo wir gerade bei den
grundrechten sind sehr geehrter herr
kollege wiese
spreche das thema durchaus mal an wir
können ja mal bei anderer gelegenheit
sie haben das thema kinderrechte im
grundgesetz hier versucht zu
instrumentalisieren wir können ja mal
bei anderer gelegenheit
folgendes besprechen wie hätten sich die
von ihnen vorgeschlagenen kinderrechts
formulierungen im grundgesetz auf die
verfolgung oder die ermittlung der
philips und edathy ausgewirkt eine
spannende frage
meine damen und herren von
gestaltungswillen der bundesregierung in
wichtigen rechtspolitischen fragen ist
nicht zu sehen die wichtigen fragen die
die menschen interessieren sind von der
union angestoßen worden ich will ihr
einige wenige beispiele nennen sie
können das mal für sich überprüfen
betrug mit geschäften mit gefälschten
pässen es war eine initiative der
unions-bundestagsfraktion die sie dann
dazu brachte die das ganze ebenfalls
verfolgt zu sehen und wir haben eine
novelle des strafgesetzbuches dadurch
bewirkt wir haben das thema
§ 64 des strafgesetzbuches auf die
tagesordnung gerufen und im gegensatz zu
ihnen mit konkreten vorschlägen
untermauert sie haben sich verweigert
meine damen und herren sie zeichnen sich
in dieser koalition sich verschleppen
und blockade aus und das trifft eben
auch das thema der sanktions schärfe
eine selten damen und herren wir haben
vor wenigen tagen hier im haus eine sehr
eindrückliche
anhörung durchgeführt
diese anhörung hat für die maßnahmen die
die koalition vorgeschlagen hat die
nicht weitgehend waren ein desaströses
ergebnis erzielt sie wissen dass selber
ihre eigenen sachverständigen haben
ihnen
den ganzen haus der öffentlichkeit
assistiert
attestiert das was sie vorschlagen
reicht nicht reicht nicht und das haben
sie dann in der anschließenden debatte
noch einmal besonders
untermalt der cool es war ein kollege
der grünen der sagte wir haben ein
genaues auge auf die villen der
oligarchen bemerkenswerterweise kollegen
feiern gibt sich große mühe immer zu
gendern sie haben auch in ihrer rede
geändert sendern oligarchen nicht
merkwürdig aber das ist nur eine
randnotiz vielleicht üben sie das
demnächst doch da hat ihr kollege
fraktionskollege gesagt sie haben ein
genaues auge auf die villen und auf die
gemälde
prima das reicht nicht die oligarch
innen haben auch ein genaues auge auf
ihre eigenen gemälde wir müssen das dazu
kommt dass wir es ihnen im reißen dass
wir das den geschändeten ukrainischen
volk zu wenden und dazu sind sie nicht
in der lage und die vorgelegten
vorschläge die haben sie nicht nur
ignoriert die haben sie abgelehnt und
das ist genau ihr problem und deswegen
hinken wir beispielsweise in deutschland
so sehr in der effektivität hinter
italien meine damen und herren
will diese
nun diese haushaltsdebatte mit folgendem
wo zusammenfassung deswegen auch wenn
der anfang meiner rede kommen es gibt
einen bemerkenswerten unterschied
zwischen der koalition und der union für
sie reicht das erzählte und für uns
zählt das erreichte denn nur das ist ein
sorgfältiges und gutes fundament für die
rechtspolitik
und der letzte regen gebracht madjid
karamac tolo spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen wir debattieren
heute mit den einzelplänen 07 19 nicht
weniger als die haushalterischen
grundlagen unseres rechtsstaates in
diesem kleinen aber bedeutsamen teil
etwa des bundesrats sind wir haben es
bereits gehört vor allem die
personalausstattung in alle wichtigen
rechts institutionen geräte diese
vielfältige justiz landschaft sichert
die rechtsstaatlichkeit in unserem land
sie ist voraussetzung für gerechtigkeit
sozialen frieden und ein stabiles
demokratisches system
wir brauchen einen funktionierenden
rechtsstaat und verteidigen ihn wo es
notwendig ist
denn was mit dem rechtsstaat passieren
kann wenn die politische macht in
falsche hände gerät sieht man vielerorts
zum beispiel in meinem geburtsland der
türkei dort befinden sich die
rechtsstaatlichkeit seit vielen jahren
im freien fall präsident erdogan hat die
gewaltenteilung quasi abgeschafft und
die justiz der exekutive unterworfen
rechtsanwälte werden zu feinden richter
zu spielzeugen des präsidialsystems in
deutschland in deutschland gibt es zum
glück einen gefestigten und
funktionierenden rechtsstaat mit
unabhängiger justiz aber auch hier
ist dieser zustand keine
selbstverständlichkeit in den
vergangenen jahren sind die kräfte
stärker geworden die unserem rechtsstaat
unsere demokratie und unserer verfassung
21 selig gegenüberstehen teilweise haben
diese kräfte es in die parlamente
geschafft unsere starke demokratie macht
dies möglich und halte es kann es auch
aushalten und dort in den parlamenten
wird dann fleißig an den stuhlbeinen
unseres rechtsstaates gesägt die wort
führenden personen entsprechen es nicht
immer offen haus am stammtisch und in
chaträumen sehr wohl da gibt es umsturz
fantasie und den wunsch nach einem
völlig anderen staatswesen die strategie
ist deutlich das vertrauen in unseren
rechtsstaat
erschüttern wo es nur geht
war der ersten lesung dieses einzelplan
im märz hatte ein mit parlamentarier der
alte herr jacobi
keine klügere idee als die
glaubwürdigkeit unseres rechtsstaats mit
hilfe eines fragwürdigen
mafiafilm zitat zu diskreditieren
bezugnehmend auf den film der pate
schilderte er wie mafiosi die
entscheidung eines gerichts nicht
hinnehmen und zitat auf anderem wege
genugtuung für geschehenes unrecht zitat
ende erwirken wollen für ein solches
verhalten machte er im folgenden das
angeblich mangelnde vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger in den
rechtsstaat verantwortlich die auf dem
einst also wenn urteile von gerichten
nicht dem wunsch bestimmte leute
entsprechen darf man sich über
selbstjustiz nicht wundern meine damen
und herren man kann ja ein alter mafia
filme seien aber eine solche
argumentation ist gefährlich und völlig
fehl am platze
zwei persönliche anmerkungen
unterstellungen gegenüber der deutschen
justiz sie sei nicht unabhängig sind ein
auch ein afro gegenüber den richterinnen
und richtern in unserem land ich
erinnere mich an den fall der getöteten
tute alba rat bei dem ich die familie
des opfers als anwalt vertreten habe es
hagelte schon vor prozessbeginn
vorverurteilungen in den medien und auch
von namhaften politikern der vorsitzende
richter hat damals bei der
urteilsverkündung sehr selbstbewusst
deutlich gemacht dass eine solche
verbale einmischung problematisch ist
eine richterin aus hessen berichtete mir
zudem neulich dass sie aufgrund der des
vom personalmangel öfter als üblich bei
organisatorischen tätigkeiten
einspringen müsse die sonst nicht zu
ihren aufgaben gehörten es sei aber ihr
wichtig mit aller kraft den rechtsstaat
zu dienen wir müssen dieses
selbstbewusstsein einer unabhängig
agierenden justiz und ihr großes
pflichtbewusstsein unterstützen und
damit bin ich beim konkreten
haushaltsentwurf wir müssen unseren
rechtsstaatlichen institutionen stärken
und ausstatten dafür haben wir in den
einzelplänen 0 7 und 19 die nötigen
gelder unterstellen eingepflegt ins auge
fällt natürlich die massive stärkung des
generalbundesanwalts das wurde heute
mehrfach erwähnt mit dem wir uns auch
auf die notwendigkeit vorbereiten
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine zu
verfolgen wir erhöhen die mittel zur
bekämpfung von hass und hetze im netz
anliegen dass wir persönlich sehr am
herzen liegt ich habe es in vergangenen
reden betont das internet darf kein
rechtsfreier raum sein dafür ist es
richtig das netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz weiter zu verbessern und zu
konkretisieren genau das schreiben hier
mit diesem haushalt an
zusammengefasst ist dieser
einzelplan justiz ausdruck davon dass
diese koalition sich den wichtigen
herausforderungen unserer zeit widmet
und für recht und sicherheit in
deutschland und in der welt eintritt
wird der kolleginnen kollegen unser
rechtsstaat ist stark und wehrhaft und
wir werden niemandem erlauben ihn zu
schwächen sondern weiter dafür kämpfen
dass er noch stärker und noch wehrhafter
wird vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
und
zu einer kurzintervention erteile ich
das wort dem abgeordneten jacobi
vielen dank herr kollege sie haben mich
in ihrem wortbeitrag jetzt dezidiert
ganz persönlich angesprochen unter ganz
konkreten bezug auf eine rede die ich
bereits vor einigen tagen hier gehalten
habe das was sie eben behauptet haben
was inhalt meiner rede gewesen sei war
das definitiv nicht sie können das in
der bild tonaufzeichnung auf der
internetseite des bundestages
nachvollziehen sie können aus sogar ins
plenarprotokoll sehen und nachlesen was
ich gesagt habe und das was sie mir eben
in den mund gelegt haben habe ich
nachweislich in keiner möglichen
auslegung meiner worte gesagt ich weiß
nicht wer ihnen das aufgeschrieben hat
was die reben vorgetragen haben ja aber
das ist etwas dafür sollte man sich
schämen ja wenn sie mir hier dinge die
ich nachweislich definitiv nicht gesagt
habe vor laufenden kameras und vor den
kopf bekommen in den mund legen ich
bitte sie sehr höflich und sehr
eindringlich dass in zukunft zu
unterlassen ihre entschuldigung nehme
ich natürlich gerne an vielen dank
[Applaus]
sie haben die möglichkeit darauf zu
wie ich habe das protokoll gelesen
möglicherweise haben sie ein schlechtes
gedächtnis daran kann ich leider nichts
aber die tatsache ist doch dass sie die
dinge immer wieder auf den kopf stellen
verbrecher werden ihre helden und
menschen die für unseren rechtsstaat
arbeiten richterinnen und richter unsere
polizistinnen und polizisten werden von
ihnen diskreditiert wissen sie ihr
verhalten wie sie sich hier verhalten im
plenum aber auch in den ausschüssen in
der öffentlichkeit das erinnert mich an
ein widget kennen viele von ihnen
vielleicht schon da fährt jemand auf der
autobahn hört verkehrs formt und dann
wird gesagt da kommt ihnen ein
falschfahrer entgegen und er sagt dann
was einer das sind ja hunderte so
verhalten sie sich sie sind der
geisterfahrer in dieser gesellschaft
akzeptieren sie dass endlich sie schaden
unsere gesellschaft und das ist das was
sie zur kenntnis nehmen müssen
damit kommen wir zum ende der aussprache
zum
einzelplan des bundesministeriums für
justiz
jacobi setzen sie sich bitte hin jetzt
ist keine weitere möglichkeit mehr der
kurzintervention wir bekommen nun
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
kommen nun zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 07
jacobi
[Musik]
wir kommen nun zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 07
[Musik]
des bundesministeriums der justiz in der
ausschuss fassung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bitte
konzentrieren sie sich auf die
abstimmung wer stimmt dafür
[Musik]
das sind die koalitionsfraktionen der
stimmt dagegen und die fdp-fraktion wer
stimmt dagegen
die linke und die cdu csu fraktion
enthaltungen dann ist der einzelplan 07
in der ausschuss fassung angenommen wir
kombiniert so abstimmung über den
einzelplan 19
bundesverfassungsgericht in der
ausschuss fassung vielleicht können wir
das noch
bevor wir zum nächsten einzelplan kommen
kommen wenn nämlich zum
bundesverfassungsgericht
in der abstimmung und zwar in der
ausschuss fassung wer stimmt dafür
dass ist das gesamte haus gegenprobe
brauchen wir glaube ich nicht mehr zu
machen dann ist der einzelplan 19
angenommen